HERE BUT WE CERTAINLY DO
APPRECIATE EVERYONE BEING HERE
AND I I'M REALLY PLEASED TO
WELCOME EVERYBODY TO THE FIRST
SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
AEROSPACE AND DEFENSE HEARING
OF TWO THOUSAND. TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY AND WE'RE LOOKING FOR
HEARING FROM OUR SPEAKERS HERE
TODAY IN MY GOOD COLLEAGUE
CENTER WILK IS NOW HERE. HOW WE
WANT TO THANK OUR DISTINGUISHED
GUESTS FOR COMING FROM ACROSS
THE STATE TO SHARE YOUR
EXPERTISE ACTUALLY HAS SOME
FOLKS COMING FROM OUT OF STATE.
AS WELL SO AND- WERE WE'RE
GOING TO BE. WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
VERY FULL HEARING TODAY SOME
ACUMEN. BRIEF BUT- WE BUT THIS
IS OF AN IMPORTANT TOPIC IT
DEALS WITH CHALLENGES OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT- DEALING
WITH THE NEW NORMAL IN OUR
STATE WE OBVIOUSLY- HAVE. HAVE
AS AS THE MAYOR OF LOS ANGELES
SAYS IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE THE
CLIMATE CHANGE IS REAL GO ASK A
FIREFIGHTER- THE YEAH WE HAVE
SEEN DESTRUCTIVE REPERCUSSIONS
INTENSIFIED BY THE CLIMATE.
CRISIS AND THE COMPLETE
DEVASTATION OF CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES UP IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IT I WAS ABLE TO.
YOU KNOW I GOOD SPIRITS TO
MYSELF IN MY OWN DISTRICT THIS
LAST YEAR AND WALKED AND WALKED
THE BURN AREA AND I AND IN THE
IN THE GETTY FIRE. AND IT WAS
REALLY- INTENSE AND DISTRESSING
AND YET I WAS ALSO IMPRESSED BY
THE- REALLY HARD WORK OF OUR
FIREFIGHTERS YOU COORDINATED
FROM ALL OVER THE STATE IN SOME
CASES THE GROUNDS AROUND THE
NATION. TO ADDRESS THE FIRE IS
THERE. ARE YOU KNOW NOT COURSE
ARE A LOT OF OTHER CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATE WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
THAT- WE STARTED TO SEE- WE'VE
WE'VE ALSO JUST GOT NATURAL
DISASTERS. IT ON THE NATURAL
HEARING CALIFORNIA THE REST
EARTHQUAKES BUT WE SEEMED.
TSUNAMI HURRICANES FLOODING.
AND MORE. AND SO THE WHOLE
FIGHT HERE IS WHAT CAN WE LEARN
ABOUT THIS TECHNOLOGY AND
DRONES TO HELP WITH EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT. AND WE'RE GONNA
HEAR TESTIMONY FROM THE
ASSOCIATION FOR UNMANNED
VEHICLE SYSTEMS INTERNATIONAL
WHICH IS DEDICATED TO THE
ADVANCEMENT OF UNMANNED SYSTEMS
AND ROBOTICS EIGHTEEN TEASE
GONNA. TALK TO US ABOUT THE USE
OF DRONES IN RESTORING
COMMUNICATION CAPABILITIES
NATURAL DISASTER AREAS. WE'RE
ALSO GOING TO HEAR FROM LOCAL
STATE AGENCIES AND FOLKS FROM
FIRE. AND OTHERS WHO WILL
TESTIFY ON THE DRUM PROGRAMMING
PROCEDURES THAT ARE USED IN
WHILE FIRE FIGHTING AND OTHER
EMERGENCIES SO. IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO TAKE A
STEP BACK AND- AND THINK ABOUT
AND LOOK AT THE EXTENT TO WHICH
WERE USING DRONES IMMERSE
IMAGINE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED. AND ULTIMATELY PART
OF THE IDEA HERE IS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO LEARN SOME THINGS THAT
WILL HELP US AS WE THINKING
ABOUT AS WE THINK ABOUT POLICY.
EITHER ON C. PRIVACY ISSUES
THAT HAVE ALWAYS BEEN RAISED
ABOUT DRONES IS ISSUES SERVICES.
WITH FOR OAKS VIGILANTE SO
DECIDE TO. YOU KNOW TO OUT
DRONES OR YOU THEIR OWN PRIVATE
BECAUSE THEY WERE. FOR WHATEVER
REASON THAT SOMETIMES GET THE
WAY OF A RUMOR SEEM WE'RE GONNA
LEARN A THAT TO SO WITH THAT
I'D LOVE TO ALLOW OKAY IF MY
OTHER CALL WANTS TO MAKE ANY
WERE BUT I TO WE SHOULD ALWAYS
OPEN HEARING. AND WE'LL START
SO LET'S START WITH ARE. ARE
YOU CAN START ART IS AT THE-
STUDENTS ARE PREGGO ARE. FROM
TO THE EIGHTEEN T. FOR DRUM
PROGRAM TO. AND TIME AGAIN
AROUND TIME GO. OUR SENIOR BY
PRESIDENT FOR ADVERTISING.
REALLY AT A YOU V. S. I. AND I
DO ALSO TO JUST GIVE US A SHOUT.
YOU A- WILL BROKE HIS WAY TO
CRAP HARD SHE'S ARE. FOR THIS
CAN. WORKS OUT OF LOS BUT IS
REALLY WERE HARD TO PULL
TOGETHER WHAT THINK AND I KNOW
WILL BE A REALLY. HEARING WE
WANT TO YOU FOR A HARDWARE. SO
WITH THAT LET'S GO TO TOM.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN AND
SENT. WILL CONSIDER JONES THANK
YOU FOR REAPED. STAYS HE- MY
NAME IS TOM. I'M SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
AND HAVE. AT A U. V. ASIDE. IF
YOU MENTIONED A UV SIZE USES.
FOR I'M VEHICLES. IN A- THE
WORLD THE WORLD'S. NOT OR-
DEVOTED. TO ADVANCING ON SYSTEM
AND- AVS BIT OF AN- TO IN THE
AIR. GROUND AND MAY. DO FOR
FIVE YEARS AND AT A- ON MANTA.
SYSTEMS ALL KNOWN AS YOU A. S.
AND DRAW. A UPS AS MORE THIRTY
LOCAL. ARE THE WORLD INCLUDING
THREE HERE AND- THE CHANNEL
ISLANDS SAN DIEGO LINDBERGH AND
SILICON VALLEY CHAPTERS PROVIDE
NETWORKING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INDUSTRY PROFESSIONALS.
INVOLVEMENT IN COMMUNITY
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS STEM
EDUCATION AND MUCH MORE. A U.
V. AS I MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA
ARE LEADING THE WAY TO
DEVELOPING TECHNOLOGIES TO
ADVANCE UNMANNED SYSTEMS. HAS
COMPANIES ACROSS THE STATE
INCREASINGLY UC'S PLATFORMS FOR
THEIR WORK. IN ADDITION TO
THEIR MANY BENEFITS FOR
COMMERCIAL USE IN INDUSTRIES
RANGING FROM REAL ESTATE.
PLEASE INSPECTION TO
AGRICULTURE. UNMANNED SYSTEMS
ARE CONTRIBUTING TO THE GREATER
GOOD. SUPPORTING MISSIONS FROM
CHESTER RELIEF TO HUMANITARIAN
AID TO CONSERVATION. CALIFORNIA
IS NO EXCEPTION. IT PLAN FOR
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT. OTHER
AGENCIES ARE ALL USING. OF
CRIME AND HAND PUBLIC SAY.
URGING AND RAPIDLY BALL TECH
WILL BE DESCRIBED MY FELLOW A
TODAY'S HE ARE HELPING TO SAVE
LIVES AND- BY ALLOWING FOR
RESPOND TO THEIR MORE IF.
EFFECTIVELY THE MOST IMPORTANT
SAFELY. HOWEVER WE REGULATION
TO THE FED AND STATE LEVEL ARE
IMPORTANT FOR FOSTERING THE
SAFE ADOPTION OF UNMANNED
SYSTEMS WHEN GOVERNMENT
INDUSTRY WORK TOGETHER TO
SUPPORT THESE TECHNOLOGIES
WITHOUT SACRIFICING INNOVATION
OR SAFETY BOTH PUBLIC AND
COMMERCIAL OPERATIONS CAN
FLOURISH. MOST RECENT REPERTORY
DEVELOPMENT WAS IN DECEMBER
WHEN THE FEDERAL AVIATION
ADMINISTRATION RELEASED ITS
NOTICE OF PROPOSED RULEMAKING
ON ABOUT IT HAITIAN YOU A S.
REMOTE UBER LAW ENFORCEMENT WE
INSTANT TRACK KEEP THE TO JUST
ALL. YOU A. S. FROM THOSE IT
MAY PAY A THREAT. WHAT ID WILL
ALSO BECAUSE OF A U. S. TRAFFIC
MANAGEMENT SO OR YOU T. M.
WHICH IS PRIMARILY BEING
DEVELOPED BY NASA THE F. RIGHT
IN CAL. OVER MY OFFICE. IT
WORKS ALONGSIDE EXISTING AIR
TRAFFIC CONTROL SYSTEM FOR
UNMANNED AIRCRAFT ETIAM ALSO
REDUCE BARRIERS TO INNOVATION
AND IMPROVE SAFETY AND SECURITY
FOR ALL AIRCRAFT OUR SKIES BOTH
MANNED. AND UNMANNED THE FAA IS
CURRENTLY SOLICITING PUBLIC
COMMENTS ON THE PROPOSED REMOTE
ID RULE AND A FINAL RULE IS
ANTICIPATED AFTER THE AGENCIES
REVIEW. REMOTE IDEAS ALSO
NEEDED TO PERMIT EXPANDED
OPERATIONS SUCH AS BEYOND
VISUAL LINE OF SIGHT AND
FLIGHTS OVER PEOPLE. WHICH CAN
BENEFIT PUBLIC SAFETY OF
WIDESPREAD EVENTS ARE EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS LIKE WILD FIRES.
THESE EXPANDED OPERATIONS WHICH
ARE CURRENTLY ONLY ALLOWED ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS ARE
NECESSARY TO IMPROVE PUBLIC AND
COMMERCIAL OPERATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. WELL THE FAA HAS SOLE
AUTHORITY OVER THE AIR SPACE
THERE ARE IMPORTANT ROLES FOR
STATE GOVERNMENTS CONCERNING
DRONE OPERATIONS. IN ADDITION
TO APPLYING TO EXISTING STATE
LAWS- FOR PRIVACY WITH YOU A.
S. SUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA
SENATE. DID WITH LEGISLATION
PASSED DURING THE LAST SESSION
CONGRESS HAS ESTABLISH A POLICY
FOR STATE AND LOCAL AUTHORITIES
TO WORK ALONGSIDE THE FAA TO
KEEP HIS GUYS IN YOUR COMMUNITY
SAFE. SECTION TWO TWO FOUR NINE
OF THE FAA EXTENSION SAFETY IN
SECURITY OF TWENTY SIX.
DIRECTED THE F. TO US A PROCESS
FOR LOW AND TRY GOVERNMENTS TO
PETITION THE FAA TO RESTRICT
YOU A. S. OPERATIONS A CLOSED.
IS TO FIX IT'S LIKE. SUCH AS
CRITICAL. WELL THE F. PLANS TO
IN A- PROPOSAL SOON REGARDING
OPERATIONS- OVER THESE
FACILITIES WITH INPUT FROM ST
CITIES COUNTIES AND TRY. THE
SECTION TO OH NINE PER WILL.
THE FAA'S AUTHORITY THE
NATIONAL AIRSPACE. AND PROVIDE
A UNIFORM REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
FOR U. S. OPERATORS TO FOLLOW.
THE FAA IS ALSO CURRENTLY
CONDUCTING A U. S. INTEGRATION
PILOT PROGRAM TO HELP
ACCELERATE SAFE DRONE
INTEGRATION INTO THE AIRSPACE
AND ALLOW STATE LOCAL AND
TRIBAL SHELLS TO RECOMMEND PER
THE RIGHT PATIENTS. NINE KEEP
PEACE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
INCLUDING IN HERE IN CALIFORNIA
IN. SAN DIEGO ARE YOU IN
CRITICAL RESEARCH CHEATING.
MINE IN MAKING ROOM IDEA AND
YOU TO MARIA. WHILE ALSO
FEEDBACK TO THE A. A. R. FUTURE
MAKING ENABLE A- SUCH AS PAC
DELIVERY. ANY PERSONAL TRANCE.
ALSO KNOWN AS URBAN AIR MOBILE.
WELL THEN OPERATIONS AS THESE
ARE VITAL TO THE SUCCESS OF
DRONE INTO. WE MUST ALSO IN
THAT THE COLLECTED TO READ.
TRANSMITTED AND SHARE. AFTER
FLIGHT OPERATIONS IS SECURE. IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN THE NATIONAL
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND
INFORMATION ADMINISTRATION
CONVENE REPRESENTATIVES FROM
GOVERNMENT INDUSTRY. AND CIVIL
LIBERTY GROUPS TO DEVELOP A SET
OF BEST PRACTICES FOR U. S.
PRIVACY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY. TO ENSURE THAT U.
S. OPERATORS ARE FLYING
RESPONSIBLY. A YOU THE S. I
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROCESS AND
THE RESULTING BEST PRACTICES
INCLUDE CLEAR CHITONS FOR
OPERATORS FOR BEST TO COLLECT
OR HOW TO BEST COLLECTED AND
STORED SECURE DATA. FINALLY WE
CANNOT IGNORE THE IMPORTANCE OF
EDUCATION IN DETERRING CARELESS
CLUELESS AND CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR.
LEGIONS OF NEW U. S. OPERATORS
MAY NOT BE AWARE OF THE FAA
REGULATIONS THAT DETERMINE
WHERE THEY CAN AND CANNOT FLY.
A U. V. S. I THE ACADEMY. AND
EXIT THE FAA PART TO LAUNCH THE
KNOW BEFORE YOU FLY PER. TO
FOUR TO PROVIDE THESE NEW. WITH
INFORMATION ABOUT OPERATING.
INCOME OF APPLE AND GUIDELINES.
THE CALIFORNIA SENATE RECORD A
NOBLE YOU FLY CAMPAIGN ARREST.
HERE OFFICIAL SOURCES SAY AND
YOU. FOR AN ACTIVE OP. OF
UNMANNED AIR SYSTEM. CALIFORNIA
LEE THE NATION THE NUMBER OF
DRONE OP. AND CRITICAL FOR
THESE BE. IN KNOW THE RULE. BY
ENCOURAGING AND CHECK WITH THE-
YOU. THE CALIFORNIA IS HELP TO
ROADS SAFETY OF AIRSPACE. MUCH
HAS BEEN ACCOMPLISHED SO IF IN
THE OF ON SYSTEMS BECAUSE THE-
AND INDUSTRY HAVE BANDED TO
ADVANCE THE OPERATIONS THIS
BILL. FOR USE BY PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES. BY CONTINUING TO WORK
TOGETHER WE CAN DEVELOP
HOLISTIC POLICY SOLUTIONS THAT
GIVE US THE FRAMEWORK TO KEEP
THE SKIES SAFE AND SECURE.
WHILE ALLOWING THE U. S.
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA TO TRULY
TAKE OFF. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY TO
LOOK FOR TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. YOU MAY HAVE. I'M
GONNA BE ON A WELCOME AND SAID
GALGIANI SEE. I ART MOVE NOW
GONNA PRESENT FROM EIGHTEEN TO.
YES THANK YOU SO I'D LIKE TO IN
YOU TO WHAT WE CALL OUR FOR CAN.
CAO STAN FOR SO ON WE- THIS IS
A- SALUTE THAT WE HAVE FOR
PROVIDE CONNECT. TO FIRST
RESPONDER UP SAFETY. AND TO THE
CHEN PUBLIC AFTER DISASTER THIS
IS BASICALLY A DRONE- THAT THAT
HAS CELL TOWER EQUIPMENT ON IT
SO IT'S OFFLINE CELL TOWER. A
FEW KEY TAKE TAKE AWAYS FROM
THE SOLUTION- IT'S VERY
RESILIENT A FLEXIBLE ADAPTABLE
QUICK TO DEPLOY- WE CAN FLY IT.
AT ALTITUDES AT FOUR HUNDRED
FEET AND WE CAN FLY FOR IT THAT
WITH A VERY SOLUTIONS FROM DAYS
TO WEEKS TO MONTHS AT A TIME
WITHOUT LANDING- AT FOUR
HUNDRED FEET WE CAN PROVIDE
CONNECTIVITY. TO UP TO TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY SQUARE MILES-
SO THAT'S A VERY LARGE COVERAGE
AREA THAT WE CAN COVER WITH A
SINGLE ROUND UP. TO SIX
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
SIMULTANEOUS CONNECTED USERS.
HER PER DRONES SO IT'S FLEX
VERY DOWN. CAN SAYS A LOT OF
PEOPLE FOR A LONG TIME OVER A
WIDE COVERAGE AREA WE FLY THESE
DRONES THROUGH A COUPLE OF
PROGRAMS THROUGH OUR FIRST NET
PROGRAM AND THROUGH OUR NETWORK
DISASTER RECOVERY PROGRAM FIRST
THAT. THAT'S A NETWORK THAT
SAID- BUILT DESIGNED BUILT- A
DEDICATED FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES FOR FIRST RESPONDERS-
THERE'S OVER TEN THOUSAND OF
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES THAT ARE
CURRENT MEMBERS OF THAT THIS
PROGRAM. OVER A MILLION ACTIVE
CONNECTIONS. ON ON THIS NETWORK
THAT'S DEDICATED TO FIRST
RESPONDERS- EIGHTEEN T. IS PUT
IN OVER FORTY BILLION DOLLARS
OF INVESTMENT INTO THIS
NETWORK. AND THE IMPORTANT
THING HERE FOR DRONES IS THERE
SEVENTY SIX DEDICATED
DEPLOYABLE FOR THE MOST PART
THESE ARE VEHICLES LIKE THE ONE
ON THE SLIDE. THAT WE CAN
RAPIDLY DEPLOYED TO RESTORE
COMMUNICATIONS- OR PROVIDE
COMMUNICATIONS TO FIRST
RESPONDERS BUT WE ALSO HAVE
DRONES- FLYING HOUSE THAT I
JUST MENTIONED. AS PART OF
THESE DEPLOYABLE SO- IN OUR
NETWORK DISASTER RECOVERY
PROGRAM THIS IS WHERE WE-
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE GENERAL
PUBLIC'S AFTER A THAT MAJOR
DISASTER WE QUICKLY RESTORE THE
NETWORK WE THIS IS A TEMPORARY.
NETWORK THAT WE PUT UP THERE
THIS IS REPRESENTS OVER SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
OF PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN
EIGHTEEN T. TO. COOPER AFTER
AFTER DISASTERS AGAIN WE HAVE
DRAWN AS PART OF THIS PRO AS
WELL. THIS ESSENTIALLY HOW ARE
STILL WORK WITH A DRONE UP IN
THE AIR YES SIR. OF. OKAY WE
WERE DRAWN UP ON THEIR ON A
TETHER IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
AND THEN THAT WE PROVIDE POWER
THAT WE CAN USE EITHER JOE WITH
HERE POWER WE CAN USE SOLAR.
AND A THE ENTIRE SO THROUGH
PANEL THE SIGNAL YOUR HAND TO
THE DOWN TO THE BASE BAND UNIT
THEN GO INTO WHATEVER OF BACK
CALL WE WOULD WE DEFAULT TO
SETTLE OF NOTHING ELSE IS OF A
BUT WE HAVE MULTI FORMS OF FACT
WE CAN. YOU HAVE IS ON DISPLAY
TODAY THAT'S WHY WE DON'T HAVE
HERE BUT WE WILL BE COMING BACK
IN A IN A MONTH SO WE'LL HAVE
IT WILL HAVE A DRAW HERE ON THE
ON THIS SO YOU CAN SEE WHAT AT
ONE OF THE THAT THIS. RIGHT
HERE. I. THE FELT LAB. IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- IN IN A
DESERT AREA AND THE DRONE WAS
WAS AT FOUR HUNDRED FEET AND WE
GOT- JUST UNDER NINE MILES OF
LATERAL COVERAGE ADEQUATE TO
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY SQUARE
MILES OF COVERAGE WITH STRONG
SIGNAL STRENGTH AND THEN TO THE
RIGHT YEAH THERE'S A COUPLE OF
AND SETS- THAT. COVERAGE
SHOWING IN A MOUNTAINOUS AREA A
TRADITIONAL CELL TOWER AT SIXTY
FEET VERSES THAT THE GRAPHIC
RIGHT BELOW IT A DRONE AT FOUR
HUNDRED FEET YOU CAN SEE THE
DIFFERENCE IN AND COVERAGE AREA
SO TREMENDOUS CAPABILITIES FROM
FROM THESE DRONES WE HAVE
VARIOUS TYPES. OF DRONE
SOLUTIONS IS NOT A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL WE DEPLOY WHATEVER
TYPE OF DROWNED IT TAKES FOR
THE THAT PARTICULAR. DISASTER
EMERGENCY SITUATION THAT WE'RE
SUPPORTING WE HAVE- TRADITIONAL
MULTI ROTOR DRONES WE HAVE
HELICOPTERS THAT CAN CARRY
ADDITIONAL WEIGHT WE HAVE AN
ALL WEATHER DROWNED. THAT CAN
FLY IN A TROPICAL STORM HER
CYCLONE IT'S PHONE AND FIFTY
SEVEN MILE AN HOUR WINDS- THIS
PARTICULAR JOHN- WHAT WAS USED
TO- RECORD IN THE GAME OF
THRONES- MOVIE FOR HBO IF YOU
SAW THE SCENES NORTH OF THE
WALL- THIS THIS WAS TO DRAW. A
LINE IN ICELAND FOR THAT-
THERE'S ALSO WE HAVE A V. TOLL
SOLUTION TAKES OFF VERTICALLY
LIKE A HELICOPTER TRANSITIONS
COLLATERAL FLIGHT. THAT WAY WE
DON'T NEED A TETHER IF WHERE
ARE OUR OVER FLY AND IT'S
RESISTANT AND- YES SIR. THE
SAID THAT THE DRAW WE CAN FLY
SIXTEEN HOURS PROVIDING
CONSTANT CONNECTIVITY AT THE
END OF THE SIXTEEN HOURS WE
LAUNCH A SECOND ROUND AND THEN
JUST JUST KEEP ROTATING THEM WE
HAVE AEROSTATS BLIMPS SIX OF
FIFTY SIX FOOT BLIMP THAT WE
CAN PUT IN THE AIR FOR A COUPLE
OF WEEKS WITHOUT LANDING WITH
MACRO CELL TOWER EQUIPMENT ON
SO THE SAME EQUIPMENT THAT WE
HAVE ON OUR CELL TOWERS WE HAVE
ON BLANKS- WITH THE END OF TWO
WEEKS IN. TOWN TOPPED OFF WITH
ADDITIONAL HELIUM PUT IT UP
ANOTHER WEEKS WE CAN ALSO DIED
TURN TRADITIONAL AIRPLANES INTO
SELF LINE CELL TOWERS AS WELL
BY PUTTING THE EQUIPMENT. ON
THEIR- ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
THAT TETHER ON THE GROUND- THE
NUMBER THREE IS A SOLUTION I
PREVIOUSLY SHOWED YOU. OF THAT-
THAT THAT THAT SOLUTIONS VERY
MOBILE WE CAN PUT IT ON THE
BACK OF AN ATV- AND THAT THAT
THE TOP LEFT IS A SOLAR PANELS
VEHICLES SO WE CAN DRIVE THAT
ON SITE. OPEN UP THE SOLAR
PANELS AND THAT PROVIDES ENOUGH
POWER FOR THE ENTIRE. TIRE
SOLUTION- THE TOP RIGHT IS OUR
FIRST NET. A SOLUTION SO THESE
TRAILERS WE LAUNCHED THE DRONES
FROM THE TRAILERS THEY ALSO
HAVE THE SATELLITE.
COMMUNICATIONS BUILT INTO THE
TRAILERS AS WELL SO IT'S ALL
SELF CONTAINED UNITS. THE
BOTTOM LEFT IS AN ALL TERRAIN-
TRAILER THAT THAT'S WHAT W
DEPLOYED TO- TO PORTO RICO
AFTER HURRICANE MARIA TO
RESTORE SERVICES THERE. BACK
CALL WE DEFAULT TO SATELLITE
BUT THAT'S NOT OUR ONLY OPTION.
WE CAN USE A MICROWAVE TO GET
THE SIGNAL BACK INTO OUR
NETWORK FREE SPACE OPTICAL-
ETHERNET FIBRE IF THE IF THAT'S
AVAILABLE IN THE CASE OF-
REPORTER RICO- WE DEPLOYED IN
A- WALMART PARKING LOT. AND
THERE WAS AN ACTIVE- FIBERLINK
AND IN THAT WALMART A WAREHOUSE
SO WE PULLED IT OUT INTO THE
PARKING LOT AND USE THAT FOR
BACK ALL INTERESTS SUPPORTED.
HIM THOUSANDS OF USERS THROUGH
THROUGH THAT THROUGH THAT
CONNECTION. THIS SHOWS. THAT AN
AREA THAT THAT'S A- WHERE IT IS
A- HEAVILY DENIED AREAS SO
THERE'S NO POWER NO-
INFRASTRUCTURE WHATSOEVER AND
YOU CAN SEE HOW WE CAN PUT UP A
PRETTY ROUGH ROBUST NETWORK
WITH THE VARIOUS TYPES OF
SOLUTIONS. THIS IS AN
OPERATIONAL SOLUTION WE HAVE
DEPLOYED AT- OF- MANY TIMES
SINCE- TWENTY SEVENTEEN- SO IT
CAN SUPPORT- EARTHQUAKES LISTEN
ARMIES- ANY TYPE OF. OF URBAN
ENVIRONMENT- WHICH DAY AFTER ST
PATRICK'S DAY PARADE WE
PROVIDED AND CONNECTIVE ITTY
THERE THERE'S A SEARCH AND
RESCUE EXERCISE WE RECENTLY
CONDUCTED. A IN THE SAN JOSE
AREA AND THE IN THE MOUNTAINS-
SO AND ALSO EVEN PGA OF EVENT
THAT'S ALSO HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WHICH WE SUPPORTED WITH THE
SOLUTION WE CAN PUT DIFFERENT
TYPES OF SENSORS DIFFERENT
TYPES OF ADDITIONAL-
ATTACHMENTS TO THESE DRONES
WHILE THEY'RE PROVIDING
CONNECTIVITY THAT CAN PROVIDE
OTHER SERVICES AS WELL. IN
DEVELOPMENT WE HAVE AN
AMPHIBIOUS VEHICLE WHERE WE CAN
LAUNCH THE DRUMS FROM
INTERVIEWS VEHICLES SO IF
THERE'S A FLOODED AREA AREAS
THAT ARE. HARD TO GET TO WE CAN
WE CAN ACCESS SOMEWHAT WITH
THIS VEHICLE WE'RE ALSO WORKING
ON A SOLAR POWERED. UP PLATFORM
THIS IS A THIRTY THREE FOOT
WING SPAN IT CAN FLY- FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS AT A TIME
WITHOUT LANDING FOR PROVIDING
HACK CONNECTIVITY. OUR
SOLUTIONS ARE ARE WE OPERATE AT
SCALE YOU CAN SEE FOR THESE
VARIOUS EVENTS A NUMBER OF
DRONES THAT WE DEPLOYED THIS IS
TO DO DAMAGE ASSESSMENT- SO IF
SAY IF THERE'S AN EARTHQUAKE IN
A. LARGE URBAN AREA WE CAN
DEPLOY HI. OF DRONES TO HELP
RESTORE THE NETWORK WE'VE EVEN
PULLED FIBER- WITH DRONES
ACROSS RIVERS AND LAKES TO HELP
RESTORE SERVICE. WE ALSO HAVE A
MEDICAL A- MEDICINE DELIVERING
SOLUTIONS EIGHTEEN T.
PROPRIETARY A SYSTEM WHERE WE
CAN MONITOR THE TEMPERATURES OF
THE OF THE MEDICINE IN ROUTE-
WHETHER IT'S BEEN TAMPERED WITH
AND THAT'S AVAILABLE AS WELL.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YEAH.
MIKE FLORIDA THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH VERY INTERESTING
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE SAID CAST
CAN FLY RIGHT THIS IS. THOSE
THOSE- IT'S A VERY VERY IT'S
OBSERVE GOOD GOOD TO SEE THAT
WORK. DO YOU FEEL WHAT WHAT
WHAT DO YOU AND- TO TELL ME
JUST GIVES A BETTER SENSE OF
EXACTLY HOW THESE ARE USED WE
WHICH WHICH THE FIRES WITH.
WHAT WAS IT WE WHICH OF THE
FIRES OF THE FLYING CAL USED IN
CALIFORNIA RECENTLY WE USE
TRADITIONAL SAT CALLS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FIRES WE DID WE
DIDN'T DEPLOY BUT THE DRONES WE
THEY WERE AVAILABLE THERE ON
STAND BY BUT- THERE WASN'T A
NEED FOR THEM IN THAT HOW DO
YOU MAKE THAT DECISION AS TO
WHICH SO IT'S USUALLY BASED ON
COVERAGE SO A TRADITIONAL SAT
CALLED HAS A TELESCOPING
ANTENNA MAST- IT'LL GO TO
SIXTY. FEET AND IF THAT PROVIDE
OF COVERAGE HERE GO WITH THAT.
WIDER COVERAGE FOR IN MORTGAGE.
TERRAIN TO ACCESS THEN WE WOULD
SEND AN- OF FLYING COW FOR
EXAMPLE THE PGA EVENT I
MENTIONED THERE'S TWO EIGHTEEN
HOLE GOLF COURSES THAT WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO SUPPORT. IT TOOK
THREE TRADITIONAL. SAT CALLS TO
COVER THAT AREA OVER THAT
TERRAIN- BUT INSTEAD WE
DEPLOYED A SINGLE DRONE. IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE TWO AREAS WE'RE
ABLE TO COVER THE ENTIRE AREA
WITH WITH ONE DRAWN SO IT'S BUT
IT'S BASED ON ON THE CONDITIONS
ON THE GROUND. OKAY ALL RIGHT
AND ARE YOU DO YOU TO WHAT
EXTENT ARE YOU HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH FOLKS AND
CAL FIRE AND OTHERS WHEN YOU'RE
MAKING THOSE DECISIONS. IS
THERE IS OUR COORDINATION OR IS
IT- SO OUR FIRST MET. TEAM
THERE'S A IT'S BY A INTERACT
DIRECTLY WITH THE PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES OF PUBLIC SAFETY SAYS
I NEED CONNECTIVITY AT THIS
LOCATION. THEN THE THAT TEAM
WORKS INTERNALLY WITHIN
EIGHTEEN T. TO DETERMINE HOW WE
MEET THAT NEED- THEY THEY AGAIN
THEY THEY GO TO SAT CULTS FIRST
IF THAT'S NOT. A VIABLE OPTION
AND THEN DOWN THE CONTACT- THE
DRONE TEAM AND WE HAVE WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE PRETTY RIVER BRIT
RESPONSE THAT WE HAVE A-
SERVICE LEVEL AGREEMENT WE HAVE
A CERTAIN NUMBER OF HOURS THAT
WE NEED TO BE ON STATION
PROVIDING CONNECTIVITY. SO
THERE'S A PROCESS TO DETERMINE-
FROM WHEN THE CALL COMES IN
WHICH TYPE OF SOLUTION IS BEING
DEPLOYED. HOW DOES THE
COMPENSATION WORKERS USE OF A
KIND OF CONTRACT. YES SO FIRST
MET. THROUGH THE FIRST NET
AUTHORITY THAT THAT'S A
DEPARTMENT WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE SO IT'S
A GOVERNMENT PROGRAM THESE-DEPLOYABLE SEARCH NO COST TO
THE PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES ARE
COVERS. CORRECT OKAY. SO THE
IT'S A TWENTY FIVE YEAR
CONTRACT SO AS AGENCIES SIGN UP
FOR THAT THAT'S A SERVICE. THEN
OUR BOB. IS ENSURE THAT THAT
SERVICES ALWAYS ALWAYS
AVAILABLE SO WE- FORMULA BY
WHICH THEY PAY. THERE'S I BUILT
A GUY I'M NOT UNFORTUNATE TEAMS
WHAT I BELIEVE THAT THEY THEY-
PAY A CERTAIN A SUBSCRIPTION
FOR SO MANY ACCOUNTS SERVED OF
DEVICES- IS SO. I OKAY. JUST
OKAY QUESTIONS EMERGENCY CENTER
BOOK. ARE YOU FROM WITH WHAT P.
S. P. S. IS ANOTHER OKAY I WALK
YOU THROUGH IT SO WE HAVE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES IN
THIS STATE AND THEY'VE BEEN
DOING THIS THING CALLED P. S.
P. S. WHICH IS PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF. I CAUGHT B. S.
P. S. BECAUSE I DON'T THINK WE
NECESSARILY NEED TO DO IT. AND
I KNOW- IN IN ADDISON WHICH IS
MY REGION ONLY TO ONLY 2% OF
THEIR TERRITORY WAS SHUT DOWN
BUT IT WAS MY DISTRICT. AND
PEOPLE LOST HOMES SO IF YOU'RE
IN A RURAL AREA IN YOUR PARA
GETS SHUT OFF. NO POWER NO
WATER COULD YOU COULD YOU POP
AND NO NO CELL COVERAGE SO ARE
THESE COWS ARE JUST SOMETHING
THAT COULD BE- IT. DEPLOYED IN
AREAS IF WE'RE IF WE'RE
EXPERIENCING A P. S. P. S.
SITUATION. IF THERE'S NO
CONNECTIVITY AND THEN IT IT CAN
BE TO DEPLOY TO RESTORE THAT
CONNECTED YOU HAD ANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH ANY OF THE
I. O. USE- REGARDING. DOING
THIS I HAVE NOT I I'M I'M ON
THAT THE DRONE SIDE SO WHAT
HAPPENS IS I GET CALLS IN.
SANTA PLAN THAT MEETS OTHERS
EXTERNALLY FACING ORGANIZATIONS
THAT WOULD WOULD MEET WITH AND
OUR- INTERFACE WITH THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS THIS IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT THAT'S VIABLE
THAT WOULD THEM IF IT. CORRECT
IS DEFINITELY VIABLE GUESSER
OKAY. VERY GOOD CAN I ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE GERMAN. HOW DO
WE BALANCE. NOT STIFLING
INNOVATION BUT ALSO PROTECTING
YOU KNOW PEOPLE'S YOU KNOW
PRIVACY YOU WANT IT I'M JUST
GOING TO KIND OF OPEN ENDED AT
LEADING GO WHEREVER YOU WANT TO
GO WE WILL BE A WHAT'S THE
PROPER BALANCE ON THAT AND THEN
TO ARE WE BETTER OFF. ADOPTING
A FEDERAL- PLATFORM SO IT'S NOT
PATCHWORK OR I JUST YOUR YOUR
GENERAL THOUGHTS ON THAT RIGHT
PUBLIC CENTER- WHEN IT COMES TO
PRIVACY IS AN ISSUE THAT THE
INDUSTRY TAKES VERY SERIOUSLY
BECAUSE WE WORK WITH OUR
CUSTOMERS WANT TO ENSURE THEIR
INDIVIDUAL PRIVACY'S. BACK IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN THE INDUSTRY AND
THE NATIONAL TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFORMATION AGENCY WHICH IS
PART OF THE PART OF COMMERCE AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. AND ALSO
CIVIL LIBERTY GROUPS GOT
TOGETHER WITH A BEST PRACTICES
FOR YOU A. S. PRIVACY AND I PUT
THAT INFORMATION YOUR PACKAGE
TODAY. AS WE FOR ALL OF US TO
GET TOGETHER TO TALK ABOUT.
GIVE ME WHAT PROCEDURE SHOULD
WE TAKE IN ORDER TO ENSURE
INDIVIDUAL PRIVACY WHEN. WHEN
OUR WHAT OUR MEMBERS THERE'S
ARE OPERATING THE DRONES AND
SO- THERE'S GUIDELINES IN THERE
ABOUT. HOW TO- WHEN YOU'RE
GATHERING THE DATA HOW YOU GO
ABOUT GATHERING DATA BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY PROTECTION THAT
DATA AND SECURING THAT DATA AND
KNOW WHEN YOU'RE GOING TO USE
THAT DATA AND WHEN YOU'RE NOT.
USING THAT DATA ANY LONGER TO
DISPOSE OF THAT DATA- BECAUSE
IT'S NO LONGER USUALLY YOU ARE
TO YOUR OPERATIONS OF THE
AIRCRAFT- BUT- WE DO AND I KNOW
OF MANY THE AGENCIES
REPRESENTED HERE TODAY AND MANY
OF. COMPANIES THAT ARE INVOLVED
IN OPERATIONS STRONG DELIVER.
ARE DOING SIR THE NEIGHBORLY
THING BY GOING OUT AND TALKING
ABOUT HOW THEY'RE GOING TO USE
THE TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE IT ONCE
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THE USE OF
THE TECHNOLOGY IN THE BENEFITS
GOING TO PROVIDE. IS MORE STEP
THE- WAY JUST AT ENDING AT
FOUR. OPERATING WHAT THE
SERVICES WILL BE PER THE AND-
PEOPLE. THEY CAN OF YOUR- THE-
DATA. GAP OF WHAT. THIS IS TO
GATHER. GOING TO USE THAT. IT
COMES TO TAKING A LOOK AT WHAT
THE POLITICIAN FOR ALL UNDER
TREAT OUR PERSPECTIVE TO DO
THAT A FEDERAL LEVEL THE
AIRSPACE TO DO OF THE FAA AND
THEY DETERMINE WHERE ERIC
WHETHER IT'S MANDER MANTA THEY
CAN FOR AND THEIR THE MESSAGE
TO THOUGH THINGS QUIRK VERY
CLOSE WITH THE F. ON SOME REAL
MAKING GOING ON RIGHT NOW KALRA
I. AND AT NAY TO HAVE A RADIO
NON PORTED DRONE SO LAUNCH OR
OTHER AUTHORITIES WHO NEED TO
KNOW WHO'S OPERATING THAT DRONE
WERE THEY OPERATING IT WILL GET
THAT INFORMATION AND AGAIN IT'S
ON A MOVE FOR SECURITY BUT DOWN
THE LINE IT WILL BE USED FOR
THIS- UNMANNED SYSTEMS TRAFFIC
MANAGER PROGRAM THAT I
MENTIONED TO HELP WITH
NAVIGATION FOR DRONES OVER LONG
DISTANCES AND HELPING IN PLACES
LIKE FOR EIGHTEEN T. IS
OPERATING. SO THEY CAN BE
INTEGRATED WITH OTHER AIRCRAFT
THAT ARE IN THAT SITUATION AREA.
FIVE YEARS FROM NOW HELP FORGET
HOW PERVASIVE ARE ARE JONES
GOING TO BE AND WHAT OTHER
APPLICATIONS. THAT YOU FOR C.
OCCURRING FIVE YEARS FROM NOW
THAT ARE NOT CURRENTLY
HAPPENING. WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT
THE FAA'S OWN FORECAST RIGHT
NOW THERE ARE ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO
ARE LICENSED TO COMMERCIALLY
FLY DRONES WHETHER THEY WERE
DOING IT FOR COMMERCIAL
PURPOSES OR CIVIL PURPOSES LIKE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OR PUBLIC
SAFETY. THEY PROJECT THAT THERE
WILL BE THREE TIMES A NUMBER OF
PILOTS WITHIN THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS SO ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND LICENSE PILOTS
BIRD FLY UNMANNED SYSTEMS. IN
UNITED STATES. SO THERE'S A
GREAT DEMAND FOR IT AS YOU SEE.
COMPANIES LIKE EIGHTEEN T.
ANOTHER UTILITIES ARE USING IT
FOR INSPECTIONS. I THINK YOU GO
TO SEE A REALLY- BIG GROWTH IN
THAT AREA JUST BECAUSE- AGAIN
THE EFFICIENCIES THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF DOING THOSE
PUBLIC SAFETY OF THOSE PUBLIC
UTILITY INSPECTIONS. AND ALSO
THE SAFETY ASPECT OF IT AS
WELL. BUT YOU CAN GET A LOT
MORE COVERAGE WHEN YOU'RE
PLAYING WITH A DRONE DOWN A
WIDE. RIGHT OF WAY THEN YOU CAN
DRIVING A BUCKET TRUCK DOWN
THAT SAME RIGHT AWAY. THE TIME
EFFICIENCIES THERE ALONE ARE A
LOT GREATER. ALSO I THINK YOU
TO SEE AN INCREASE IN PACKAGE
DELIVERY- PACKAGE DELIVERY NOW
IS JUST- PRE NASCENT INDUSTRY.
IS JUST STARTING PLACES LIKE
VIRGINIA NORTH CAROLINA. THAT
WE HAVE ONE PACKAGE DELIVERY
COMPANY HERE FROM CALIFORNIA
TODAY U. S. O. G. RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE THE ONLY PACKAGE
DELIVERY COMPANY IN. CALIFORNIA
BUT I THINK WE'LL JUST SEE MORE
OF THAT AS THE FAA COMES UP
WITH REGULATIONS AND GUIDANCE
ON HOW TO OP. THAT SYSTEM. Q.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ABOVE OUR
PALACE AGREE RESPECT ON FRIDAY
SECTOR ENGAGEMENT THIS AREA
WERE NEXT CAN HEAR FROM- COUPLE
VOICES FROM TE LOCAL LEVEL WHO
WORK CLOSELY WITH WITH- WITH
YOUR PRODUCTS- SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU
SENATOR SO OUR NEXT PANEL AND-
INCLUDES CATHARINE GIFFORD IS
FROM SACRAMENTO MUCH FUN FIRE
DISTRICT AND THEN ALSO
COMMANDER TIME MATT AGAIN.
WHO'S WITH ALAMEDA COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND WE'LL
START WITH YOU KATHY GIFFORD.
THANK YOU. GET MY STUFF HERE OR
WHEN YOU WHERE WE NEED TO BE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING. AS
CENTERS OF MONEY TRYING
DIFFERENT I'M A CAPTAIN WITH
SEGMENT MUCH FALLEN FIRE
DISTRICT HERE IN SUFFOLK COUNTY
I'M ALSO YOU AB PROGRAM MANAGER
FOR OUR AGENCY WE STARTED A
ABOUT FOUR YEARS AGO BEEN
ACTUALLY FLYING FOR THE PAST
THREE YEARS- UNDER TWO
DIFFERENT FAA SHIFT ITS
AUTHORIZATION AND PART ONE OF
SEVEN AUTHORIZATION METROPARK
COVERS ABOUT THREE FIFTY SQUARE
MILES. THE GREATER PART OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY ON A FORTY
STATIONS- COVER PRETTY MUCH
EVERYTHING FROM. LIGHT
INDUSTRIAL COMMERCIAL URBAN
RURAL AND ABOUT NINE MILES A
SEGMENT OF RIVER- IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN MEASURE
FIRING ABOUT NINETY SEVEN
THOUSAND CALLS FOR SERVICE FOR
YOU THAT YOU GUYS ARE A COUNTY.
TO WEAR SPECIAL DISTRICT BUT WE
ARE EFFECTIVELY A COUNTY AGENCY
WHERE WHERE SPECIAL FIRED ISSUE
BECAUSE WE COVER MORE THAN-
JUST SECOND COUNTY WE ALSO
PUSHING THE PLASTER- SO LIKE TO
ORDER HOW WOULD YOU. OKAY THIS.
INCLUDES CITY SACRAMENTO AS
WELL NO SEGMENT OF OUR
DEPARTMENT IS ETERNITY- BUT IT
DOES INCLUDE THE CITIES OF
CITRUS HEIGHTS FAIR OAKS- AREAS
IN CARMICHAEL ARDEN. BASED AND
IN MOST OF THE- SO YOU DOWN
THEY'LL- AND PUSH OUT CITY SOME
HAS INVITED. AND THEN UP TO
CITY ROSE. AND THAT WE DO HAVE
AN AREA PLASTIC AS WELL THAT
COVERAGE WHY THIS BY DISTRICT.
TOM ARE YOU YOU PROGRAM. HAS
ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT PILOTS IN
SOME LEVEL OF TRAINING FROM
BRAND NEW ALL THE WAY UP TO YOU
FULLY QUALIFIED AND- AND FLYING
LIGHT MISSIONS. WE FIND OUT
SIXTEEN AIRCRAFT CURRENTLY. A
DIFFERENT- MODELS. AND WE ARE
JUST UNDER A THOUSAND MISSIONS
THAT WE'VE FLOWN IN THE PAST-
THREE YEARS SINCE WE'VE BEEN
FLYING ACTIVELY- COUPLE OTHER
THINGS WERE INVOLVED WITH
BESIDES MATTER FIRES. YEAR THE
PROGRAM- WE ALSO COORDINATE THE
SACRAMENTO- REGIONAL UAV
OPERATORS GROUP WHICH IS.
TWENTY EIGHT LONG FIRE AGENCIES
IN THE GREATER SACRAMENTO AREA
THAT IT BASICALLY FORMA SOCIAIS
XIN TO TRADE BEST PRACTICES AND
WORK WITH EACH OTHER TRAIN EACH
OTHER WE JUST HAD A- AND DATE.
THE SECOND. IS THE OTHER DAY.
I'M WE'RE ALSO INVOLVED WITH
FIRE SCOPE FOR. HIM FAMILIAR
FIRES AS FAR SCOPE IS A- POTS
AND PRACTICES GROUP THAT WAS
FORMED IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES- FROM SOME. BAD FATAL
FIRES IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EFFECTIVELY A FIRE SCOPE IS
GROUPING OF. AND FIRE AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THE GET
TOGETHER IN DIFFERENT
COMMITTEES TO FIVE TO FORM
POLICY MISS PRACTICE THAT'S HOW
WE GET ALL THAT INFORMATION PUT
TOGETHER AND PUT OUT SO THAT.
WHEN THERE'S A LARGE FIRE
THAT'S HELD FIRE ENGINES FROM
UP HERE GO TO THE SOUTH OR FROM
THE SOUTH AND COMMITTEE
HELICOPTERS. UNIT TYPING
PERSONAL TYPING ALL THE OTHER
PARTS AND PIECES TO GO ALONG
WITH THAT A FIRE SCOPE HAS BEEN
SO SUCCESSFUL THAT LOT OF
THINGS HAVE COME OUT FIRES A
COUPLE OF YEARS HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL
PHONE IS A COMMAND SYSTEM. AS
ADOPTED BY NATIONAL LEVEL AS
NAMES- NATIONALISM MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM IT'S A DIRECT COPY OF
THIS SYSTEM IS BUILT BY FIRE UP
THROUGH CALIFORNIA- SO WE SAID
ON THE U. S. SUB COMMITTEE TO
AIR OPERATIONS SPECIALLY GROUP
FOR FIRES WERE ON THE TO TRYING
BUILD UPON. WHAT STATE LEVEL
LOOKS TO GET YOU A THE ASSET
AND DOWN THIS IN TIME OF MAJOR
NOT JUST QUALIFY AND WE'LL SEE
A SHORT HERE THAT ONCE THE FANS
BUT- IN A SENSE OF EMERGENCIES
STATE WHY. OUR SCOPE ROSS
INVOLVED WITH GROUP CALLED
JONES PONDERS IS NOT LEVEL.
MATTER EXPERT GROUP THAT'S- TO.
TRYING TO FIND. BE TRAIN DEPLOY
THAT. WHAT SOME OF THE STUFF
NEEDS TO BE REGIONALIZED A LOT
OF IT NEEDS TO BE FEDERALIZED
IN TERMS OF IT'S A NATIONAL
STANDARD OR IT'S A NATIONAL
UNDERSTANDING HOW IT'S BEST TO
BE DEPLOYED- THAT'S HOW
EMERGENCY SERVICES WORKS WE DO
OUR WORK IN A REGION. BUT WE
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING
ON ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT WE
WERE ALL IN THIS PRACTICE WITH
EACH OTHER- WE ALSO HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY SIT ON NASA'S
STEREO GROUP WHICH IS. A
SCALABLE TRAFFIC MANAGEMENT
FROM BURNS RESPONSE OPERATION
STEREO IS- BUILDING A MANTRA
MANS PROGRAM WHICH WAS SPOKE
ABOUT EARLIER. BASICALLY A
SYSTEM SIMILAR TWENTY AFTER
CONTROL DOES FOR MANNED
AIRCRAFT BUT IT DOESN'T FOR
UAVS THERE'S A LOT OF
CHALLENGES TO THAT BUT IT
BECOMES A- TRACKING SYSTEM
SPECIFICALLY INTERESTING FOR-
LAW ENFORCEMENT FIRE BECAUSE IT
LETS US KNOW WHERE OUR ASSETS
ARE. AS WELL AS MANNED ASSETS.
SO THAT'S KIND OF WE COME FROM-
OUR IN OUR AGENCY WERE.
FORTUNATE DEEPLY INVOLVED- I'M
BASICALLY GOING TO GO OVER THE
TOP OF THE- HILL AND JUST SOME
BACKGROUND ON WHAT WE'VE DONE.
IN THE GO. TO SEE IN PUBLIC
SAVE HAS IN EVERY RECENT IT'S
REALLY IN WONDER WHY IT GIVES
US THE ABILITY SEE THAT
COULDN'T SEE THE TO GO WE
HADN'T BEEN IN TO GO BEFORE
THESE TECHNOLOGIES THAT HAVE
BEEN LIMITED BECAUSE OF COST OR
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS SO YOU AB
USER ARE COMMON ENOUGH SAYING
NOW IN THE FIRE SERVICE IN
THEIR SMALL ENOUGH AND PORTABLE
ENOUGH THAT WE CAN GET THEM
ANYWHERE. PREDOMINATELY WHAT
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT IN. RECENT
HISTORY HAS BEEN USE ON WATER
LAND- INCIDENTS WILDFIRES AND
THEY THEY SURE GREAT PROMISE
FOR THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
YOU WILL ABSOLUTELY SEE MORE OF
IN THE STATE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. JUST THE ABILITY TO
GET THIS TYPE OF YOU FOR AN
INCIDENT COMMANDER- IN IN THE
INITIAL STAGE OF FIRE THIS
MIGHT BE BEFORE MAJOR RESOURCES
GET THEIR- IS PRETTY EPIC. THIS
IS A DEMONSTRATION- THIS IS A
LIVE FIRE. THIS IS ONE OF OUR
PILOTS OVER FLYING A UNIT THAT
WAS BEING RE DIRECTED BY THE
INCIDENT COMMANDER IN SICK MAN
WAS USING THE FOOTAGE COMING.
BACK THE A LIVE STREAM. TO GET
THAT ENGINE TO TURN LEFT THERE
WHEN THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHERE
THEY WERE GOING TO GET TO THE
SPOT FIRE THAT YOU'RE GONNA SEE
UP HERE IN SUPPORT ANOTHER UNIT
THAT WAS ACTIVELY WORKING. AND
YOU CAN SEE WHAT THE CONDITIONS
LOOK LIKE IT'S TOUGH TO SEE
FROM THE GROUND. BUT THE
ABILITY TO PUT A- LIGHT
AIRCRAFT OVERHEAD AND BE ABLE
TO IMMEDIATELY HAVE THAT
INFORMATION. AND PUSH IT BACK
TO AN INCIDENT COMMANDER- IS
HUGE IN THE FUTURE- WE
CURRENTLY USE VIDEO STREAMING
TECHNOLOGY ALLOWS US TO
BASICALLY PUSH OUR IMAGES TO
ANY. OF OUR AUTHORIZED FOLKS
ANYBODY CAN SEE IT IN THE
FUTURE. PUSHING IT TO
INDIVIDUAL AND COMPANIES
BECOMES A VERY VIABLE
ALTERNATIVE AS WELL INDIVIDUALS
ON THE GROUND SIMILAR TO WHAT
THE MILITARY DOESN'T CASES.
THIS IS A- FOR CONSTRUCTION
FIRE. LIMITING TO CYCLIC HELP.
BUYING A- HOT OF THE GROUP WERE
ABLE TO LOCATE. SO BY JUMPING
OVER THE TOP OF THIS AND USING
FOR IMAGING WORKING IT WERE IN
TO. GET THEM WHERE THEY NEED BE.
THAT'S A FAIRLY SENSE. MEASURE
FAR COVERS. NOW MILES AND-
RIVER AND- WE A LOT OF TIME ON
THE RIVER THERE'S A LOT OF ROOM
REST CALLS A ON EVERY YEAR IT'S
A VERY. HOT RIVER IT'S HEAVILY
USED- SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE DO THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
UNIQUE TO SOME OTHER PARTS OF
THE COUNTRIES WE SPEND A LOT
TIME OVER WATER- WHETHER IT BE.
SEARCH AND RESCUE
IDENTIFICATION OR OVERSIGHT AS
THIS IS HERE'S HIS TRAINING
WITH- FAMOUS CALIFORNIA TASK
FORCE SEVEN OVER THE RIVER-
GIVING THE INCIDENT COMMANDER
OF THE CREWS ON THE GROUND A
BETTER VIEW OF WHAT THEY'RE
GETTING INTO. IS A PRETTY HUGE
PART OF WHAT THE CAMERA SYSTEMS
ALLOW- SPECIALLY WHEN YOU START
LOOKING AT THE COST OF THE
CAMERAS BEING RELATIVELY
INEXPENSIVE FOR THOSE IN
TECHNOLOGY AND THE CLARITY THAT
THEY'RE BRINGING- THESE
AIRCRAFT CAN BE WASTED OFF IN A
VERY SAFE LOCATION. AND STILL
GIVE YOU PRETTY IMPRESSIVE
IMAGERY- THIS AIRCRAFT IS
PROBABLY A LINEAR DISTANCE OF
ABOUT A THOUSAND FEET AWAY. AND
THAT'S- THE TAX INFORMATION WE
CAN PULL BACK FOR A SICK
MATTER. TECHNICAL SEARCH AND
RESCUE SOMETHING THAT'S ALWAYS
BEEN A DIFFICULTY IN THE FIRE
SERVICE IT'S ONE OF THOSE
THINGS IT'S UNIQUE. A NOT A
SELDOM USED SKILLED WHEN IT
NEEDS TO BE IN- EMPLOYED IT'S
KIND OF THE ONLY THING. MORE
THE ONLY SEES TO IT SO. THE USE
OF YOUR VISA CRAFT TO JUMP OVER
THE TOP OF A COLLAPSE THIS IS
COLLAPSE DOWN AND BEAR TO
IMAGERY AND TO PUT THAT A MAJOR
ON A REAL FOR OUR SEARCHERS TO
BE ABLE TO YOU KNOW WHERE
THEY'RE SEARCHING WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING AT WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR IS FAIRLY IMPRESSIVE IT
ALSO HELPS US TO PUT AYE AYES
INTO A SITUATION THAT MAY NOT
BE SAFE TO PUT OUR PEOPLE INTO
THE WE CAN LOOK IN. THE WHOLE
LAST THING THAT OTHERWISE WE
WOULDN'T. A TECHNICAL RESCUE-
ONE OF THE INTERESTING PARTS OF
TECHNICAL RESCUE IS THAT IT
HAPPENS ABOVE AND BELOW GRADE
SO WE'RE NOT NECESSARILY ON
LEVEL- THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
USES WHERE BEING ABLE TO STAND
BACK AND GIVES THE RESCUE TEAMS
INCOMING RESCUE TEAMS ARE
INCIDENT COMMANDERS VIEWS OF
WHAT WE'RE CURRENTLY DOING AND
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN NEXT.
ALLOWS IN THE PRE PLAN AND PRE
DEPLOY THEIR RESOURCES IT'S
REALLY HARD ON TECHNICAL RESCUE
CALLS TO GET THE HARDWARE THAT
YOU NEED IN POSITION FINALLY
MANNER BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH
OF IT- KNOWING WHAT YOU'RE
GETTING INTO AHEAD OF TIME LETS
YOU PREPAY AND THAT SO WE'RE
FLYING ON THE BACK. OF THE
CHIEFS RIDE. AND BASICALLY
GIVING THE INCOMING TEAM OF YOU
OF WHAT THE OUTCOME TEAM WAS
DOING I'VE ALSO DONE TRAINING
RECENTLY WITH- FLYING THE LINES
OF THE TOP OF OPTICAL SO
INSTEAD OF PUSHING A LINE OUT
WITH A LINE DOWN WE CAN DO IT
NOW WITH AIRCRAFT AS MATERIALS
ONE OF THE AREAS WHERE WE SEEN
HUGE INCREASE OVER THE STATE
ARE OVER THE COUNTRY.
ESPECIALLY IN THE EAST COAST.
BEING ABLE TO PUT AN AIRCRAFT
IN POSITION WHERE YOU DON'T
WANT TO PUT PEOPLE AND GIVE-
THE HAZMAT TEAMS OF YOU. OF
PERHAPS AERIAL GAS MONITORING
WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE DOING THERE
WERE FLYING GAS MONITORS
THROUGH A PLUME AND ALLOWING
RESOURCES ON THE GROUND SEE
WHERE THAT PLANE IS. MODEL IT
FIGURE OUT HOW FAR IT'S GOING
TO STRETCH OUT. IS A REALLY
INTERESTING CONCEPT FOR USE.
BECAUSE IT DOES. FLOOD HERE WE
DO FLOOD OPERATIONS AS WELL THE
OVER FLAT FLAT OPERATIONS IS A
FAIRLY. MAJOR USE CASE FOR US
WHEN IT'S RAINING. GETTING
AHEAD OF A FLOODED AREA BEING
ABLE TO GO OUT AND LOOK AT
AREAS THAT ARE CURENTLY FLOOD
AND SEE WHETHER THAT'S GOING TO
IMPACT OUR ACCESS AND EGRESS TO
THAT AREA. IS A HUGE PORTION OF
GETTING US IN POSITION TO MAKE
EFFECTIVE RESCUES WHEN IT
BECOMES NECESSARY IT'S PRE
PLANNING GETTING OUT WHEN IT'S
FLOODED BEING ABLE TO LOOK OVER
THE TOP OF A GIVE ARE BOTH
COMPANIES AND OUR GROUND CREWS
IN VIEW. OF WHAT'S GOING ON
CURRENTLY SO THAT IN TWO HOURS
IF THEY GET A CALL FOR
ASSISTANCE THEY KNOW KIND OF
WHERE WE'RE AT ALREADY- THIS IS
A LIVE. MISSION THIS IS A
RESCUE MISSION FOR A DRIVER WHO
DROVE THROUGH SOME CLOTHES ROAD
SIGNS AND ENDED UP FLOODING IS
VEHICLE OUT. WE ARE ABLE TO
OVERFLY THIS EVEN WITH THOSE
TREES AND GET A VIEW FOR OUR-
FOR OUR RESCUE TEAM BEFORE THEY
WALKED IN SO THEY KNEW WHAT
THEY WERE WALKING INTO WE ALSO
HAVE THE CAPABILITY TO DO
PAYLOAD DELIVERY. SO WE CAN
RELEASE PFDS ON- PERSONAL
FLOTATION DEVICES. ON TO PEOPLE
WHO MAY BE STRANDED ON THE
RIVER- OR IN A FLOOD SITUATION
AS WE KEEP THEM SAFE. THIS IS
MERRY. RIVER WHERE PEOPLE
REASON LIKE TO PUT. IN EVERY
COOPER STREET IS AN ACTIVE
SCENES ARE BOTH CREWS WILL GO
OUT AND TRY TO MAKE CONTACT TO
MAKE SURE THERE'S NOBODY INSIDE
THAT VEHICLE. THE OVERSTATE THE-
BE ERICA. OVER THE HEAD AND
GIVES. CREW A GREAT VIEW OF
WHAT THEY'RE GETTING INTO
BEFORE THEY GET THERE. SO
THAT'S JUST SOME OF THE USES.
WE FOUND FOR OUR CRAFTING WE
SEE THAT USE REALLY REGION WIDE
BETWEEN LINE FIRE- THE FUTURE
THAT IS MORE. IN DEPTH AND
COMPLICATED SENSORS ARTISTS A
LOT OF SENSE IS BEING USED
ANOTHER VERTICALS AGRICULTURE
IN INDUSTRY THAT WILL END UP
BEING ADOPTED IN AS WELL AS
RAPID MAPPING- AND SEVERAL
OTHER USES. TYPICAL INTERESTING
THANK YOU THIRTY GOTTEN WILL.
NEXT HEAR FROM- A BAY AREA
PERSPECTIVE COMMANDER. MATT
AGAIN FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY. IT'S
THE WORK ORDER I NEED TO GET TO
THE SCREEN. ALL RIGHT SEE HERE.
THE NOW THAT THAT CAR THAT WE
SAW THE KIND OF A GHOST WHEN
WAS WAS THAT. ONLY THE PEOPLE
GOT OUT. WORD YEAH THERE IS
NOBODY INSIDE OF THAT THAT'S A
SECTION RIVER WHERE IT SEEMS
LIKE KIDS LIKE TO PUSH CARS
INTO THE RIVER. I DON'T LITTLE
PUSH THEM IN THEIR FAST AND
THEN WE GO. TO GO OVER THE EDGE
SEARCHES AND FAIRLY TECHNICAL-
SEARCH AND RESCUE TECH KIND OF
OPERATIONS- HAPPENS AT NIGHT
FAIRMOUNT TO AND AN ACTIVE AND
IT WASN'T COMING. I GUESS KIDS
BEING KIDS SURE I DON'T KNOW
WHY THEY DO IT BUT OBVIOUSLY WE
TREAT ALL OF THEM IS.
POTENTIALLY FIVE WERE IN THAT
CASE NOT LIVE REPLIED THE
RECOVERY BUT LIVE RESCUE TYPE
KIND OF MISSIONS. SO YEAH
THAT'S IT'S A USE. THANK YOU.
THERE ARE. WHAT'S AT THE-
USUALLY THEY GET BUT WE CAN AND
LEFT IN PLACE UNTIL THE WEATHER
IS STABLE ENOUGH AND THEN THE
EITHER BRING IN BARGES SAID
IT'LL BE CONTRACTOR BRINGING
BARGES ARE BRING IN TOW
VEHICLES DEPENDING ON WHERE IT
IS A PROBLEM OUT BUT THERE'S
MOVIES OUT THERE FOR CARS THAT
ARE GONNA GET PULLED DOWN
BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY CAN'T- THEY
KEEP VOTERS AWAY FROM. THE SO
THE THANK YOU CENTERS FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY AND WE'RE
WE'RE HAVING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES THE PRESENTATION
IS ON THE SCREEN BUT IT'S NOT
UP THERE SO I WILL MAKE SURE
THAT YOU YOU FOLKS GET THE
LINKS TO WHAT I AND HAD
INTENDED TO SHOW TODAY- MY
NAME'S TOM AT ECONOMIC
COMMANDER WITH THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE DOWN
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA I
WORK FOR AND- SHARE FAYE HEARN.
W WERE EARLY ADOPTERS OF THE
US TECH NOT. IN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE WERE ONE OF THE
FIRST AGENCIES EVER TO BE ABLE
TO DEPLOY US TECHNOLOGY. WE
HAVE- INTER TWINED U. S.
OPERATIONS INTO. ALL THE
BUSINESS WE DO- OUR SHARE OF
HIS IN MUTUALLY COORDINATOR FOR
REGION TWO SO WE HAVE IT'S MOST
ACTIVE MUTUAL AID REGION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO WE
DEPLOYED PEOPLE ALL P AND DOWN
THE CITY CALIFORNIA TO ASSIST
WITH- A DANGER TO TUITIONS
WHETHER IT BE A NATURAL
DISASTER ALONG. RELATED EVENT.
I JUST WANT TO SAY ONE THING.
AS A DOT. SAY THE STATE
INTEGRATION OF YOU A OF AN AIR
THE THERE IS THERE IS HIGHWAY
IN THE SKY AND WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE FLY THE SINGS IN A
SAFE MANNER SO WE NEVER HAVE
ANY INCIDENT INVOLVING A MANNED
AIRCRAFT AND UNMANNED AIRCRAFT
IN IN SOME SORT OF ACCIDENT
WERE WERE PEOPLE GET HARMED- TO
THAT AND I WANT TO KNOWLEDGE
THE CALIFORNIA- WHO IS. ALLOWED
US ACCESS TO FLY YOU A. S. IN
THEIR TEETH FAR AS IN THEIR
TEMPORARY FLIGHT RESTRICTIONS
DURING SOME DISASTERS IN IN
GRADED SAFE AND THOUGHTFUL
MANNER AND THAT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANCE TO BE ABLE TO- UAVS
IN MY OPINION- REALLY COOL MEN.
THE WORK DEMAND. IF THERE. FULL
CORDON FULL MANNER THE BE DONE
NOW WE USE YOU A OP ROUTE IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO AREA IN VERY
COMPLEX AIR SPACE IN IN
COORDINATION WITH- WITH MANNED
AIRCRAFT THEM WHERE THEY'RE
TALKING EVERYONE KNOWS WHAT
ALTITUDE THAT THERE AT WHAT THE
WHAT FOR FLIGHT PARAMETERS WE
HAVEN'T SO THAT'S JUST REALLY
AN IMPORTANT POINT THAT THINKS
IT IS TO BE MADE. AND OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AND WHAT I
HAD INTENDED SHOW YOU AND WE'LL
SEND YOU LINKS IS. WE FIRST.
STARTED USING YOU AS IN%
DISASTER SCENES ON BACK AT THE
TRAGIC GO SHIP FIRED OAKLAND
WHERE- THIRTY SIX PEOPLE
TRAGICALLY LOST THEIR LIVES. IT
WAS THE FIRST TIME WE REALIZE
THE U. S. COULD ADD VALUE TO
THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT THE
FIREFIGHTERS IN SEARCH AND
RESCUE PEOPLE ARE DOING. IN
TERMS OF LOOKING FOR VICTIMS
THERMAL IMAGING FOR HOT SPOTS
PRIOR TO SENDING PEOPLE INTO
DANGEROUS AREA. AS VERY
IMPORTANT STUFF SO WE LEARNED A
LOT FROM THAT TRAGIC INCIDENT
AND THAT THE FIRES IN THE NOMA
CAME ABOUT IN COFFEE PARK THE
TRAGEDY IN COFFEE PARK AND I
HAD A MAP HERE TO SHOW YOU OF
THAT. WHERE WE TO THOUSAND BASS
LOW LEVEL AND STITCH THEM TO.
INTO NOR OF MUSIC MATT. SO THE
CITIZENS LIVE THERE BUT
COULDN'T BACK IN COULD TAKE A
LOOK AT THE MAP. DOWN TO STREET.
IN A ONE WHAT HAPPENED TO THEIR-
SEE WITH HAVING TO GO INTO SO.
THAT MAPPING REAL AND AS PART
OF A INTO GRAY AMBER MAY
STRATEGY FAST FORWARD TO THE
FIRES IN IN REDDING WE DID SOME
MORE MAPPING OUT THERE BUT THEN
WE ALSO LEARNED THAT A SMALL
DRONE CAN CAN BE SET UP IN THE
SKY AT A HUNDRED FEET TWO
HUNDRED FEET OR WHATEVER CAL
FIRE ALLOW. AND TAKE A QUICK
SERIES OF SNAPSHOTS IN STITCH
TOGETHER IN INDIAN ALMOST
INSTANTANEOUSLY- A MODEL OF
WHAT WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
NEIGHBORHOOD WHICH STAND CAN BE
UPLOADED TO THE COUNTY OR
CITY'S WEBSITE AND RESIDENTS
CAN CLICK ON IT AND SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD-
FAST FORWARD TO BUTTE COUNTY. A
YEAR AFTER THAT. WE WERE ABLE
TO GO UP WITH THE TEAM A TEAM
OF THE UAV OPERATORS FIFTEEN
DIFFERENT EAMS. WITH THE
PERMISSION OF CALIFORNIA THE TO
IN A COORDINATED MANNER- TAKE.
SEVENTY THOUSAND PHOTOGRAPHS
OVER FIVE HUNDRED FLIGHTS IN
AND OUT OF HERE FOR YOU IN TWO
DAYS AND STITCH THOSE TOGETHER
WHERE- PEOPLE COULD LOOK AT THE
DAMAGE THEIR PROPERTY. AND THEN
WE USE A NEW TECHNOLOGY CALLED-
SURVEY WHERE WE ENTER WE
OVERLAID VIDEOS WERE NOT ONLY
COULD YOU SEE YOUR YOUR
PROPERTY BUT YOU COULD SEE A
VIDEO FLY THROUGH OF YOUR
PROPERTY. SO I TRULY BELIEVE
THAT THE MAPPING IS CRITICAL
FOR DISASTER ZONES- IN IN IS
THE FIFTH AT THE FEET COULD BE
INTERRELATE OVER A SERIES OF
DIFFERENT LAYERS YOU KNOW
THERE'S MAPPING LAYERS. IN THIS
U. S. DATA. CAN BE THEM LATE
INTO THAT. ALSO IN TERMS OF
URGENCY RESPONSE. I CAN'T COME.
OVER TO MADE THE THERMAL
IMAGING CAPABILITY- IN SO NO MY
COUNTY WHEN PEOPLE WERE
UNACCOUNTED FOR AND THE
AUTHORITIES HAD LIKELY AREAS
WHERE THESE PEOPLE SHOULD BE.
TO SEND A UAV AN AUNT AND GET A
THERMAL IMAGE A THERMAL READING
BEFORE SENDING A SEARCH AND
RESCUE PERSON BEFORE STANDING
CANINE IN THERE TO AREAS ARE
STILL HOT. REALLY IN OR
TECHNOLOGY AND ALL DIFFERS THE
SCENE. YOU KNOW TO TAKE AN
AERIAL PHOTOGRAPH AND PRESERVE
THE SCENE. SO A WHOLE WHOLE
CLOTHES ARE MAKE SURE YOU GET
THE LINKS BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THIS
COMMITTEE SEE THIS DATA- AND
JUST IN CLOSING I'D LIKE TO
SAY. I'M FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I
THINK OF IT ALL PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD UTILIZE
UHS TECHNOLOGY FOR THEIR FIRST
RESPONDERS BECAUSE IT CAN HELP
THEM DETECT DANGERS THEY COULD
OTHERWISE NOT SEE AND KEEP THEM
SAFE- AND MAY NEED TO INTEGRATE
THEM INTO THE WORK THAT THEY DO
EVERY DAY SO WHATEVER BARRIERS
YOU FOLKS. CAN REMOVE TO HELP
THEM GET PROGRAMS ESTABLISHED I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO SUMMIT
SINCE. BECAUSE THE PULSE HELLO.
CAN'T USE A TECH. THAT CAN
THEIR FI. AND OFFICERS FROM
FROM LOSING THEIR LIVES. AND
THANK YOU FOR HEARING ME OUT
THANK YOU COMMUTER I LOVED IT
JUST- FOLLOW UP ON THAT LAST
COMMENT I'M YOU REPRESENT AND
POLITICALLY ACTIVE COUNTY YES-
ALAMEDA COUNTY- IT CAN YOU CAN
YOU WEEK WE MENTION POLITICS
WHAT WHAT WE TALK ABOUT WHICH I
MIGHT. PRIVACY ACTIVISTS OR
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. FOLKS ARE
JUST KIND OF SKEPTICAL ON FORCE
MANNER OR WELL SOON SO WHERE
EVER I STILL REMEMBEREDTHE
FIRST BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
MEETING AND- GIVE A
PRESENTATION AS CHAIR OF THE-
PRINTER. THE CHRONICLE ROAD OR
THE A COVER STORY EAST BAY AT
THE FOREFRONT OF THE- BAIT AND
HOW. THE PEOPLE SHOWED UP.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON. SPOKE AND
TRY TO DO EVERYTHING HUNDRED
SPOKE AGAINST WHAT WAS THEIR
ARGUMENT. PRICE CAN IT WAS
MAINLY PRIVACY CONCERNS. AND SO
WE COMMITTED TO BE TRANSPARENT
TO THE PROCESS AND I CAN TELL
YOU FIVE YEARS LATER THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF FLIGHTS WE
HAVE RECEIVED NOT ONE SINGLE
COMPLAIN. ABOUT INFRINGING UPON
ANYBODY'S PRIVACY NOT A SINGLE
ONE. AND SO- YOU KNOW THERE'S
LOCAL AGENCIES WHERE A U. S.
COULD ADD VALUE BUT THEY'RE
HESITANT TO BRING IT IN BECAUSE
OF THE BACKLASH ASSOCIATED WITH
IT. SO BUT FROM WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING. YOU KNOW YOU YOU HAD
ALL THIS. KIND OF FEAR CONCERN
IN ITALY YES WE TOOK STEPS TO
IMPLEMENT STRICT. PRIVACY
PROTECTING PROTOCOLS MINUTES AS
A RESULT. IN SPITE OF. ALL THAT
NEGATIVE ENERGY THOSE OUT THERE
IT'S YOU'RE NOT FACING
CRITICISM NOT NOT AND NOT ANY
AND SO THE ROBUST PUBLIC
OUTRAGE SUMMERS. YOUR MODEL MAY
BE A INSPIRATION OR SOMETHING
TO BUILD UPON ELSEWHERE STATE
YOU WERE TRYING TO HELP PEOPLE.
LEARN FROM OUR PART BUT- IN
SOME STATES TO DO ONE OF THEM
HI BUT HELL. REYES TECHNO. WELL
AT AM I. THINK THE IT'S A MIXED
MY NO. ALUM COUNTY. WE WERE THE
ONLY U. S. TEAM AND NOW I'D SAY
AT LEAST HALF OF THE POLICE
AGENCIES AND HALF OF THE FIRE
DEPARTMENTS ARE. THEY RECOGNIZE
THE VALUE AND THE VALUE IS IT
IS GETTING THEM THERE THE
MAPPING YOU KNOW THAT CAN BE
DONE AFTER THE FACT BUT THE
LIFE THREATENING EVENT IT'S
TRANSPIRING RIGHT NOW. IS WHERE
IT IN REAL TIME IS WHERE THE
TRUTH TRULY ADD VALUE- THEY
THEY HAVE TO BE THERE IN A
TIMELY MANNER- YOU KNOW THE WAY
THAT. WE'RE LOOKING AT A BAY
AREA IS WE A LOT OF MANNED
AVIATION ASSETS SO IF IT THE
HELICOPTER GETS THERE FIRST.
FROM WHAT THE UAVS IN ROUTE
ONCE ONCE THE UAV TEAM IS THERE
IF YOU HAVE A DEFINED INSTANT
PROMOTER TO ME IT IT IT. CAN BE
DONE WITH THE U. S. A LOT
CHEAPER AND JUST AS IF MORE FAT
THAN A COPPER SO COPTER CAN BE
ON WHAT'S NEXT AND THEN THE US.
TEAM IS THERE. WORK PROBLEM FOR
DOWN IN A STAGGERED MAN TO IT
SIX ABOVE THE GROUND THE U.
WILL NOT GO THAN A AND FIFTY
FEET IT'S CHOREOGRAPHED AGAIN
BECAUSE OF THE CONCERN OF THE
SAFETY ISSUES SO ACTION AND
NATIONAL WILD FIRE CORNING
GROUP- AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL IS
DONE A GREAT JOB OF BUILDING A
PROGRAM OUT THAT ALLOW FOR MAN
AND MAN IMMIGRATION IN A VERY
SIMPLISTIC AND STRAIGHTFORWARD-
AND IT'S WHAT WE USED ON THE
FAR SIDE. TO INTEGRATE ACROSS
LINES WE'VE WE'VE HAD GREAT
SUCCESS IN OUR REGION IN
WORKING WITH BOTH- LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND FIRE
HELICOPTERS AND KEEPING
EVERYBODY WHERE THEY NEED TO BE
IN TO BE SAFE AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE LOOKED AT TO
ADOPT AT THE STATE LEVEL TO
MAKE THIS. A WILL PEACE THERE'S
NO IT'S A IT'S A FOOT RAY
EVERYBODY ON. THIS TRYING TO
BUILD PROGRAM- I'VE HELPED A
COUPLE DIFFERENT REGIONS BILL
REGIONAL OPERATING GROUPS. AND
MY FIRST DATE WITH THEM IS
YOU'RE NOT ALONE YOU'RE NOT
DEALING WITH TRYING TO DO THIS
I GUARANTEE YOU JUST SEND AN
EMAIL TO EVERYBODY AROUND YOU
ALL ALONG FIRE AGENCIES. AND
ASK IF THEY WANT TO COME TO A
MEETING. AND YOU'LL BE
SURPRISED WHO SHOWS UP. ONE OF
THE GREAT THINGS ABOUT THAT AND
THAT COORDINATION AND
COMMUNICATION AND THAT THAT
REGIONAL LAST THAT REGIONAL
GROUPING MODEL. IS THAT IT
HELPS ADMINISTRATORS FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH IT ONE OF
THINGS THAT CAME UP WAS THE
IDEA OF WHERE'S WHERE'S THE
PUSH BACK IS IT IS A- PUBLIC
SIDE IS IT ON THE- MISTER SIDE
AND- AT. HIM DIFFICULT FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES
ADMINISTRATORS TO WALK DIVE
LONG TO PER LIKE THIS. YOURSELF
OUT THERE IS A LOT OF SCRUTINY
IT'S CAL. THERE'S PUBLIC- LOT
OF PUBLIC PROTECTION IN PLACE.
BY HAVING MULTIPLE AGENCIES.
ALREADY WORKING WITH AN
ORIGINAL OPERATING GROUP GIVES
AS ADMINISTRATOR SOMETHING TO
LOOK AT TO GO OKAY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DOING THAT. THERE ARE.
PRACTICES ARE THERE ARE OTHER
AGENCIES LEAN ON TED HEY WHAT'S
WORK FOR YOU WHAT HASN'T. AND
WITH WITHIN THEIR OWN CIRCLES
THEY- BOB DUFF AND- THAT'S- I
KNOW THAT'S PROOF. IN OUR AREA.
THE HILL IN THE- CONTRACT
REGION WHERE THEY- REGIONAL.
GROUP AND I WOULD JUST. AS WELL
HELPFUL WE WANT TO GO THIS
ALONE IN A- AS A MINISTRY YOU
HAVE. BEEN RESPONSE. AND YOU
HAVE TO DO IT RIGHT. RIGHT THE
SENSE. ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU
COMMANDER CAPTAIN FOR SHOULD
PROCEED ALL THE HARD WORK THAT
GOES BEHIND YOUR PRESENTATIONS
TO. ALRIGHT LET'S LET'S NOW
WE'RE GONNA WE WENT FROM THE
LOCAL NOW WE'RE GONNA JUMP UP
TO THE STATE LEVEL- WE'RE TALK
ABOUT STATE USE OF REMOTELY
PILOTED VEHICLES. IN EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AND WITH THAT WE'RE
GONNA HEAR FROM CALLOW YESTER
ACTOR MARK YOUR DO CHEAP. CHIEF
TOM PORTER FROM CAL FIRE AND
THEN MAJOR GENERAL BALDWIN.
FROM CAL GUARD AND- WE'LL START
WITH YOU DIRECTOR. NICE ONES
GET THE NAME PLATES. FIXED THE
COMMUTER. OKAY OUR REGION ALL
RIGHT EXCELLENT. ALL RIGHT WELL
GOOD MORNING PART OF ITALY'S
YOUR NAME FROM- NORTHERN ITALY
LOOK AT LOOK AT OF YEAH HAVE
YOU BEEN HALF **** BRIDGE. WALL
BACK WORLD CITY YEAH. WELL GOOD
MORNING AND- MEASURE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE REALLY HAPPY TO
BE WITH YOU TODAY AND TALK A
LITTLE ABOUT- THE OPPORTUNITIES
AFFORDED BY THESE NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE'VE JUST BEEN
SEEN SOME GREAT PRESENTATIONS
ON ANDREALLY PHENOMENAL-
EXPLANATION ON THE USE AND HOW
ARE OUR BOTH OUR PRIVATE SECTOR
PARTNERS AND OUR GOVERNMENTS
ARE ARE USING THESE WERE-
REMOTELY PILOTED AIRCRAFT OR
ALSO KNOW MAYBE AS UNMANNED
AERIAL VEHICLE OR DROWNED-
YOU'LL HEAR FROM MYSELF AND MY
COLLEAGUES HERE ARE PUBLIC
SAFETY OF A LEADER CALIFORNIA
THAT. WE REMAIN REALLY KIND OF
A NATIONAL LEADER IN THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY FOR WHILE FIRE
DETECTION AND VALIDATION A
RESPONSE IT IS CONSTANTLY AND
WE'RE CONSTANTLY SEEKING
INNOVATION AND EMERGENCY
MANAGED TO BETTER PREVENT
MITIGATE AND RECOVER FROM ALL
SORTS OF DISASTERS. CLOSE THE
TIMELY AND EFFECTIVE USE OF A
DROP INS AND THE PRINCIPAL
BENEFITS OF THESE SYSTEMS IS
THE SPEED AT WHICH THEY CAN BE
DEPLOYED FOLLOWING AN INCIDENT
AT THE ABILITY TO COLLECT I
FORGET ON THE INTELLIGENCE IN A
COST OF. MANNER ARE DRUGS CAN
BE EXTREMELY USEFUL IN DISASTER
PLANNING AND PREPAREDNESS THEY
CAN BE USED TO MAP IS IN OF
STORMS AND OTHER NAY DISASTER.
IF I KEY A THAT ARE GOAL OR
MIGHT BE DOES. IF AND THE MATH
CONDEMNED AVAILABLE TO FOR
RESPONDERS EMERGENCY MANAGER
FOR FUTURE EVENTS. BEFORE AND
AFTER IMAGES ARE PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE PRIMARY-
PRIMARY DAMAGE ASSESSMENT
FOLLOWING DISASTERS. AND IN THE
SET ESSENTIAL STEP. TOWARDS
POTENTIALLY QUALIFY FOR FEDERAL
DISASTER ASSISTANCE FOLLOWING
DISASTER EVENTS IN FACT- YES
USED- A DRONE- KEY. DRONES FOR
COUNTY THE NUMBER OF DAMAGED
HOMES FOLLOWING THE WILDFIRES
AND FLOODING EVENTS- WE'RE
STANDING WATER WAS PRESENT AND
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
NORTH BAY FIRES. CALORIE AS YOU
LAST DRUGS TO EXPEDITE.
ASSESSMENT IN THE CITY OF SANTA
ROSA IN ORDER TO MOVE. BUT THE
STATE'S. PRESIDENTIAL MAJOR
DOES DE. OF THE- OF THE MISSION
MAN. ITSELF TENDS MILLIONS
DOLLARS. STATE LOCAL
RESPONSIBLE COVERAGE EFFORTS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
EARLY ON IN THE PROCESS WHAT IT
NEEDED TO ALWAYS VERY VERY
INSTRUMENTAL THEIR DRAW PAUL'S
AND IN. AS WELL AFTER HURRICANE
AS YOU HEARD FOR NAY AND OTHER
NATURAL DISASTERS ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT. HAS BEEN DIFFICULT TO
GET AROUND- GROUND UNITS IN THE
AFFECTED AREAS. DOZENS OF DRUGS
WERE USED IN RESPONSE TO
HURRICANE HARVEY IN HOUSTON
AFTER HURRICANE IRMA IN
FLORIDA. JONES CAN IDENTIFY
STRANDED PEOPLE MORE RAPIDLY.
AND AT LOWER RESEARCH BIRDS HE
PERSONNEL- THEN GROUND UNITS
AND THEY CAN DLIVER WATER
MEDICAL SUPPLIES RESCUE
EQUIPMENT. AND OTHER
NECESSITIES OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
BRANCH FOR EXAMPLE HAS COURTED
SEARCHER SQ OPERATIONS USING-
NATIONAL GUARD. ADDRESS BALLING
TALK IN A FEW MINUTES THEY'VE
BEEN YOU TO A FIVE LOS HIKERS
THE DRUGS HAVE HIGH POWERED
CAMERAS THAT CAN ALLOW CLEAR
IMAGE IMAGES FROM A GOOD HEIGHT
AND THERMAL IMAGING SAYS.
IMAGING SENSORS THAT DETECT
HEAT MAKING THAT PARTICULARLY
EFFECTIVE AT NIGHT- THE DATA
FROM THE DRUGS CAN BE. PROCESS
IN REAL TIME AND SOME DRONE
SOFTWARE CAN DISCERN A PERSON
AN ANIMAL OR VEHICLE FROM JUST
A HANDFUL OF PIXELS RECOGNITION
SOFTWARE CAN BE OPERATED
THROUGH A MOBILE PHONE MAKING A
VERY COST EFFECTIVE TOOL TO THE
RESPOND OR ON THE GROUND. HELLO
YES ALSO WORKING WITH CAL FIRE
IN THE U. S. FOR SERVICE
EMPLOYEE DRONES IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN AND TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. TOGETHER INFORMATION
ON THE EXTENT OF TREE MORTALITY
IN WALL AND AREAS DURING THE
DROUGHT HELPING TO ESTIMATE THE
POTENTIAL FUEL FOR WILDFIRES.
ARIES APPEAL INFESTATION- IN
DEAD AND DYING TREES AND SITES
MOST NEEDED IN AND A NEED OF
HAZARD ME THROUGH TRUE. AS OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE BRANCH
IS EQUIPPED TO USE DRONES WITH
VIDEO AND STILL IMAGE RECORDING
CAPABILITIES FOR OPERATIONS
INSPECTING POWER INTO. INTENT
LAW AND DID HIS FOR FOURTEEN
MAINTENANCE OR DAMAGED AFTER
BASS. SURVEY MIKE. FOR
OBSTRUCTION. OF. LEAGUE WE'RE
HELPING TO DEVELOP STATEWIDE-
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SUPPORTS A
GREATER INTEGRATION UP OUR PA
TECHNOLOGY BUT WE ARE A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT FIRE SCOPE OUR
EARLIER THAT'S IS ON THE FAR
SIDE WERE ALSO WORKING WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT COUNTERPARTS. IN
FOR THE BUILD OUT OF REGIONAL
CAPABILITIES. AND OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMUNICATION BRAD'S AS
A BUILD UP THE NEXT GEN NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM WERE PROVIDING-
IP CONNECTIONS THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE USED TO TRANSMIT
VIDEO AND OTHER INFORMATION
FROM A DRONE. AS WE COMPLETE
THE FIRST THE FEASIBILITY STUDY
FOR EIGHT NINE ONE ONE. WE'RE
ALL LOOKING AT STATEWIDE
COMPUTER AIDED DISPATCH AND
DATA SHARING OPPORTUNITIES THAT
COULD BE. USED TO HELP
FACILITATE THE TRANSFER VIDEO
AND DATA FROM A DRONE MUCH LIKE
WE TALKED ABOUT WHAT YOU HEARD
OUR OUR INITIAL PRESENT AT THE
PRESENT PRESENTERS TALKING
ABOUT- THE IMPLEMENT
IMPLEMENTATION OF TECHNOLOGY
WILL REQUIRE- AND INCLUDE
SIGNIFICANT PROTOCOLS AND
SAFEGUARDS TO ENSURE THE DRUGS
ARE USED APPROPRIATELY
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT. AND DRONE
USE DOES NOT THREATEN LIVES
SAFETY PROPERTY PRIVACY RIGHTS.
OR EFFECTIVE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE. AS THE STATE'S
HOMEMADE SECURITY AGENCY WE'RE
ALSO WORKING ON SECURITY
CONCERNS CREATED BY DRONE USE
IN THE STATE. SUCH AS CHINESE
DEVELOP DRONES COUNTER
INTELLIGENCE AND THE THREAT OF
CONTRABAND TO PRISONS
CALIFORNIA IS AT RISK. TO THE
UNAUTHORIZED AND MALICIOUS USE
OF DRONES DUE TO AN ABUNDANCE
OF ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY
DEVELOPMENT IN THE STATE. AND
THE STATE'S EXTENSIVE
INFRASTRUCTURE PORTFOLIO. THE
STATE A THREAT ASSESSMENT
CENTER HAS ASSESSED THE
CALIFORNIA. WAS THE NATION WIDE
LEADER IN TWO THREE NINETEEN
FOR ON AUTHORIZE. ON IN. THIRD
CONSECUTIVE. CAL TO EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA HAD. BEFORE OF THE
WAY THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ON A- OWN ENCOUNTERS
MOST WHICH OCCURRED IN LOS. THE
THAT THE IS GOING INTO EITHER
RESTRICTED AIRSPACE OR- COMING
A CONTACT CLOSE CONTACT WITH A
COMMERCIAL AIRLINER. THOSE ARE
THOSE MOSTLY ENTHUSIASTS YEAH
RIGHT SUMMER MEDIA DRIVEN AND
SOME ARE- SOME ARE. PRIVATE
PHOTOGRAPHERS MY TO GET GET
PHOTOS- REALLY DELAYED BECAUSE
THAT'S MOST PEOPLE ARE YEAH I
JUST OF DENSITY POPULATION AND
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF THE
MEDIA MARKET IN LA IS PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT SO THEY A LOT OF
THOSE- JONES HAVE. AND CITED AT
AIRPORTS STADIUMS CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES AMUSEMENT PARKS
POLITICAL EVENTS. AND OTHER
HIGH COMPLEX AND DYNAMIC
SITUATIONS MAKING DRONE USE AN
OBVIOUS SECURITY CONCERN FOR
THE STATE AND YOU KNOW IT'S A-
KEY CONCERN ON THE SECURITY
FRONT LIKE WHEN WE HAVE. A
MAJOR SPORTING EVENT LIKE THE
SUPERBOWL OR EVEN JUST. AN LA
RAMS GAME OF FLYING DRONES OVER
THE STADIUM AND THE POTENTIAL
FOR DROPPING. CERTAIN KINDS OF.
BIO HAZARD OR OTHER KINDS OF
THING THE COULD COULD IMPACT
PUBLIC IN RECENT YEARS THE US
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
IN STATE ALL MY SECURITY
AGENCIES HAVE WORKED ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF- DRONE
COUNTERMEASURES THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF. OF DRUNK
COUNTERMEASURES ARE DEPENDENT
ON THE SIZE OF THE DRONE THE
DISTANCE OF THE DRONE. WHO
CONTROLS THE DEVICE AND WHETHER
THE DRONE IS LOCATED IN U. S.
TERRITORY. COUNTER DRONE
DETECTION AND TRACKING SYSTEMS
ARE AVAILABLE IN A VARIETY OF
FORMS INCLUDING A RADAR. RADIO
FREQUENCY ELECTRO OPTICAL
INFRARED ACOUSTIC AND COMBINE
SENSORS- THE COUNTER- DRONE
TECHNOLOGIES USED ARE DEPENDENT
UPON THE TARGET. AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. ADDITIONALLY
AUTHORITIES REGARDING DRONES
COUNTERMEASURES RESIDE ONLY AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL CURRENTLY.
AND THAT'S ONE THING THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE THOSE AUTHORITIES
EXTENDED DOWN THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL IS THE PROTECT.
CAPABILITIES OF FOLKS CAL FIRE
WHICH MIGHT OF FIGHT FIRES IN A
CAMP BECAUSE THE TOP ARE BEING.
IMPACTED THE BROWN. SO WHETHER
STABBING IN THIS ASK AREA DATA
FOR MY RECEIPT RESCUER. THE OF
AUTHORIZED ONCE. PHONE AND ON
TO MEASURES IN A- THE BILL TO
ENHANCE CAL OF THE PLAN PREPARE
WE TO AND RECOVER THREATS AND
HAS THROUGHOUT STATE AND SO IT
FOR THE OPPORTUNITIES A LOT
ABOUT THIS WHOLE TECHNOLOGY- TO
NEW AND- YOU KNOW- WERE BIG
STICK A LOT OF ACTIVITY GOING
ON. THE ONLY STATE THIS THE
BEAM STATES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO ROUTE THE UNITED ARE REALLY
DEVELOPING A CAPABILITY SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. OUR
NEXT CENSUS YOU ORDER. THANK
YOU CHAIR A AND MAY OF THIS
COMMITTEE- FOR HAVING THE A
CHANCE TO ADDRESS YOU AND GIVE
YOU KIND OF A BRIEFING ON WHAT
KIND OF USES WE ARE- CURRENTLY
SEEING. FROM CAL FIRE- AND IN
THE WHILE IN FRONT OR WANT TO
GET ANY FEEDBACK GIVE THAT BACK.
AND AGAIN TO A COUPLE THINGS
THE FIRST TIME THAT I'M AWARE
OF USING- THIS- REMOTELY
PILOTED AIRCRAFT KIND OF
SYSTEMS FOR OUR OWN USE- AT CAL
FIRE- WAS WAS- ACTUALLY- FATAL
ACCIDENT ONE OF OUR
FIREFIGHTERS- WAS HIT BY
ANOTHER VEHICLE ON THE SIDE OF
THE FREEWAY. AND KILLED- WE OUR
OUR- SAFETY- FOLKS IN RIVERSIDE
UNIT HAD A CAMERA MOUNTED ON A
ON A SMALL REMOTELY POWER-
PILOTED AIRCRAFT AND WERE ABLE
TO AGREED THE AREA AND WE USE
THAT FOOTAGE FOR- FOR OUR
SERIOUS ACCIDENT REVIEW VERY
KEY- TO HAVE THAT VIEW AND THAT
CAPABILITY. IN THAT KIND OF
TYPE OF- SCENARIO SO THE FIRST
TIME THOSE TWO THOUSAND TEN.
AFTER THAT ANALOGY I'M GONNA
GET MORE INTO WILD FIRE WHAT
WHAT WAS THE WILD FIRE KIND OF
A SETTING FOR THIS THE SMALL
REMOTELY- BISLETT AIRCRAFT ARE
ARE GOOD FOR SMALL AREAS OR AS
YOU CAN STAY AS WE HEARD IN-
THE PREVIOUS- TESTIMONY.
THEY'RE THEY'RE GOOD FOR SEEING
CERTAIN PARTS OF FIRES BUT WHAT
WE FOUND WAS- WE WENT INTO A
PERIOD- AROUND 200-013-1213
WHERE WE ARE STARTING TO HAVE
MASSIVE WILDFIRES. MIGHT HAPPEN
EARLIER THAN THAT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT TECHNOLOGY
HADN'T CAUGHT UP. SO WHERE WE
ARE- IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
IS THE RIM FIRE OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
ACRES JUST APPEARED STANISLAUS
NOW NATIONAL FOREST. AND WE
USED- AT THAT TIME- CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD M. Q. NINE-
PREDATOR TYPE. ASSISTANT
VIEWING OF THE FIRE TO WATCH
WHAT WAS HAPPENING ON THE
GROUNDS TO IDENTIFY PERIMETER
IDENTIFY HOT SPOTS IDENTIFY-
SPOTS OVER LINES AND LOOK AT
THE PROGRESSION AND WHERE THE
FIRE WAS. LIKELY TO IMPACT BOTH
OUR OUR CREWS ON THE GROUND BUT
ALSO- OR- COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
TRYING TO PROTECT THAT WAS THAT
WAS THE FIRST LARGE SCALE USE-
AND IT WAS VERY TELLING AS TO
WHERE THE TECHNOLOGY WAS GONNA
TAKE US. WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
CONSUME IT IN THE WAY THAT WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO CONSUME IT
AND WE ARE STARTING TO CONSUME
IT CURRENTLY. WE COULD SEE
THINGS BUT WE COULDN'T
COMMUNICATE TO THE GROUND
TROOPS WHAT WAS HAPPENING AT
THEIR LOCATION THAT WE COULD
SEE- FROM A DISTANCE. SO
MOVING- AND DIRECTOR GIL DUDE
SHE MENTIONED- USE OF AGAIN AM
TO NINE TECHNOLOGY AND OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES- AS A- TIME SORRY
SORRY COMMANDER MATT AGAIN-
MENTIONED IN THE- THE NORTH BAY
FIRES WE USE THAT DURING FIRE
ACTIVITY AS WELL AS POST FIRE
FOR DAMAGE ASSESSMENT AND-
NEIGHBORHOOD KIND OF-
INFORMATIONAL CAPABILITIES-
VERY- IMPORTANT ONE OF THE ONE
OF THE UNIQUE THINGS THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO DO. WITH M. Q. NINE
AND HOT A HIGH LEVEL OF- AND-
KIND OF OFF IN THE DISTANCE
PERSISTENT LOOKING IS WE WERE
ABLE TO WATCH WHAT THE FIRE WAS
DOING. AROUND AND ABOVE- YON
PHIL- THE VETERANS HOME WHICH
WAS WAS- THREATENS THROUGHOUT
THAT THAT- PERIOD AND VERY MUCH
OF A CONCERN WE NEVER HAD TO
EVACUATE. ALL OF THE YOUR BILL
SILLY BECAUSE WE WERE ABLE TO
WATCH AND SEE WHAT WAS GOING ON
AND MAKE REAL TIME
DETERMINATION THAT THAT WAS NOT
GOING TO BE A THREAT. SO WORD
WE'VE USED- AGAIN AM TO NINE
AND OTHER- NATIONAL GUARD
TECHNOLOGIES- WITH- THE
CAMPFIRE WOLSEY- THE HILL FIRE
MENDOCINO COMPLEX THE CAR FIRE
FERGUSON ALL OF THESE FIRES
WERE JUST IN. TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ALONE. AND WE BEND
CONTINUALLY DEPLOYING A AND
REQUESTING- BOTH THROUGH-
CALLOW YES MISSION TASKING BUT
ALSO A DIRECT- REQUEST TO THE
GUARD WHICH WE HAVE.
AUTHORIZATION TO DO HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THEY WERE THE ONLY
CAL OR ALMOST ONLY STATE IN THE
NATION THAT CAN DO THAT. FOR
EMERGENCIES RELATED TO
WILDFIRE- WE CAN DEPLOY- THESE
TYPES OF SYSTEMS FOR OUR USE. A
VERY IMPORTANT INTERESTINGLY AS
WELL WE'VE WE'VE ENGAGED- WITH-
NOT ONLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT- BUT
ALSO PRIVATE VENDORS- WE USED A
PRIVATE VENDOR FOR- THE
CAMPFIRE ORIGIN DETERMINATION
SO WE CAN GET A VIEW OF THE AND
A VERY ARTICULATED- AND FINE
GRAIN VIEW OF THE SITE WHERE
THE CAMPFIRE ACTUALLY START.
VERY IMPORTANT FOR WORK. YOU
CAN SEE HOW I AM I'M NOT GONNA
GO INTO ALL OF THOSE OTHER-
USES A CAL FIRE IS THE SINGLE
LARGEST FIRE DEPARTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE USE-
TECHNOLOGY AND HAVE THE NEED
FOR TECHNOLOGY JUST AS CAPTAIN
GIFFORD- MENTIONED AND SHOWED
WE GET WE CAN AND WILL NEED TO
DO MORE OF EVERYTHING THAT WAS
HIS TESTIMONY- FROM THE FIRE
PERSPECTIVE AND WE SUPPORT THAT
FOR ALL OF THE FIRE SERVICES-
ON FIRE USES THAT ARE MORE
SPECIFIC TO- CAL FIRE. OR FIRE
PREVENTION EFFORTS MAKING SURE
THAT THE ARE ARE LOOKING AT ARE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND OTHER
TYPES OF ISSUES. EIGHT ORIGIN
AND BECAUSE I ALREADY MENTIONED
ALL OF THAT I VERY IMPORTANT-
THE ALL HAZARD- USES THAT THAT-
CAPTAIN GIFFORD MENTIONED. BUT
ONE THAT THAT IS A LITTLE MORE
UNIQUE TO- CAL FIRE MISSION
WHICH IS TO OUR OFFICES STATE
FIRE MARSHAL IS. A HAZARDOUS-
LIQUIDS PIPELINES AND THE
ASSESSMENT OF- ISSUES RELATED
TO THOSE- BOTH ON THE
INSPECTION SIDE BUT ALSO-
DETERMINING WHERE THERE MIGHT
BE ISSUES. THOSE LINES LEAKING
AND OTHER OTHERWISE- THE A
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
APPLICATIONS AS DIRECTOR GIL
DUDE SHE MENTIONED VERY
IMPORTANT FOR OUR OUR- RESOURCE
OUR OUR FOREST MANAGEMENT-
NEEDS AND RESILIENCE. OF OUR
FOREST AND MONITORING THAT THE-
APPLICATION FOR LOOKING AT ALL
ANY OF OUR FACILITIES AND-
REMOTELY DETERMINING WHERE WE
MIGHT HAVE SOME SOME ISSUES OF
MAINTENANCE OR OTHERWISE. KEY
IN CLOSING I'D LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE THIS RPA ARE.
SOMETHING THE CALIFORNIA- NEEDS
AND WILL USE- GOING FORWARD FOR
BOTH WILD FIRE AND ON FOR
AWHILE FIRE OPERATIONS- WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL TO- AND
APPRECIATIVE OF OUR ABILITY TO
WORK WITH- CALLOW YES AND- CAL
GUARD IN DEPLOYING THESE
RESOURCES TO MEET THE MISSION
OF OUR DEPARTMENT TO SAFE ARE
THE PUBLIC. AND MITIGATE- IT'S-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
LOOK FORWARD ANY QUESTIONS
WHEN. TIME ALLOWS EASY FOR HER
WE'RE NEXT TO HEAR FROM ME
GENERAL BALL WHEN HE'S GOT A
VERY IMPRESSIVE. THE RIBBONS IN
MY PENS HIS WE WOULD ARE YOU
MOST PROUD ON YOUR UNIFIED
AMERICA. MOST OF OUR JUST FOR
SHOWING UP TO WORK THAT. THE
ESPECIALLY PROUD OF THE KID I'M
DAVE I'M THE BALDWIN THE ENGINE
GENERAL CALL WHICH I CAN THEE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD THE
AIR NATIONAL GUARD AND OUR OWN
STATE CARD AS MENTIONED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH- YES AND CAL
FIRE IN TWENTY THIRTEEN WE
PIONEERED THE FIRST USE OF
LARGE MILITARY DRONES- FOR
DOMESTIC SUPPORT LOW FORTIES
SINCE THEN WE'VE MATURED
INVOLVED ARE PROCESS SEES SO
NOW WE ROUTINELY USE BOTH ARE
LARGE. NATIONAL GUARD DRONES AS
WELL AS OUR ARMY NATIONAL
GROWTH CARD DRONES TO CAL FIRE
WITH FIRE MAPPING ASSIST- YES
WITH DAMAGE ASSESSMENT AND WE
BEEN DONE SIR. USE WE FOR THE
SURVIVOR BECAUSE OF THE A
CAPABILITIES OF THE DRAW
AIRCRAFT PUT UP. ON A WEAK TO
MATURE. OUR TACTICS AND
TECHNIQUES AND DOING THIS AND
QUIRK CONCERT MAINLY WITH CAL
FIRE AND OUR INTELLIGENCE
ANALYSTS AND WE'RE BEGINNING TO
INTEGRATE WITH OUR DRONES TO
TEAM THEM WITH SPACE SPACE
SYSTEMS. PREVIOUSLY CLASSIFIED
SYSTEMS THAT WE CAN NOW USE TO
GET BETTER IMAGERY AND TWO Q.
AND TO DETECT RAPIDLY OF FIRE
STARTS ON OFTEN BEFORE SOMEONE
SEES A RECALLS NINE ONE ONE WE
CAN QUEUE THAT. GET THAT OVER
TO CAL FIRE DISPATCHERS GET A
DROPPER HAD THEY'RE ABLE TO-
PUT THOSE FIRES OUT VERY
QUICKLY- THE LATEST THING WE'RE
WORKING UP IS INCORPORATING-
THE DEPARTMENT OF. SOCIAL CAL
ABILITY TO. EVEN MORE LEAVE THE
USE COMPUTERS. TO BE ABLE TO
PROTECT AND ANALYZE FAR STARTS
AND POTENTIAL THREATS- OUR
NUMBER ONE. PRIORITY THIS YEAR
TO THE US KHAN IS EXPAND OUR
DRAW FLEET BY ADDING- CORRECT
EAGLE AIRCRAFT WHICH IS AN ARMY
NOW GUARD LARGE DRUM SYSTEM.
WHICH WILL INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF DRONE WE HAVE. CALIFORNIA
SAN. MORE BILL. YOU CHALLENGE
THAT WE ARE THE WE FACE IN
DEALING WITH REMOTELY PIE
AIRCRAFT AND DRUM MAKE HAS TO
DO WITH FORTIES THE FIRST IS
DIRECTOR GIL DO SHE MENTIONED
IS THE AUTHORITY TO DEPLOY A
CAT ARE YOU A US SYSTEMS SO
THAT WE CAN- EITHER TAKE
CONTROL OR DENY THE USE OF
POTENTIAL ADVERSARIES OR JUST.
PEOPLE THEY'RE GOOD FOR AROUND
THE GET IN THE WAY OF FIRE OR
CONTRABAND INTO PRISON SMUGGLE
STUFF ACROSS THE BORDER WE EVEN
HAD AN INCIDENT WHERE. OUT A
WEEK SOMEONE WAS FLYING A DRONE
OVER OUR ALERT F. FIFTEEN
FIGHTER JETS. AT OUR BASE IN
FRESNO THEY'RE FULLY ARMED
AIRCRAFT- NOW WE THINK THAT WAS
JUST AN ENTHUSIAST BUT A
CRISPIN SOMEONE THE MENTAL
HARM. TAKE THAT DOWN WE DON'T
THERE ARE FAA RESTRICTIONS
AGAINST IT NOR DO WE HAVE THE
CAPABILITY. SO WE DON'T YET
HAVE FIELDED IN THE ARMY
NATIONAL GUARD OR THE AIR
NATIONAL GUARD FOR YOU WORK
WITH THE FAA TO TRY TO GET TO
ADDRESS THE WORK OF THE FAA AND
WE'RE ALSO WORKING WITH YOU. TO
DEVELOP AND PROCURE ASSIST THAT
WOULD REALLY AND BUS TO. A
DEFEAT DRONES THAT WE DON'T
WANT FLY AROUND WE WOULD MAINLY
USE AND SUPPORT CAL FIRE AND
CORRECTIONS. HERE IN THE STATE.
THE OTHER AREA THAT WE HAVE
CHAPTERS IS JUST WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO USE. THE AUTHORITY
TO USE LARGE- YOU AS OR
REMOTELY PILOTED SYSTEMS RIGHT
NOW THE ONLY ITEM IN IN THE
INVENTORY THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD THAT- THE
GOVERNOR OR I CANNOT DIRECT IN
ROME OR FORTY TO USE IN SUPPORT
OF. CAL FIRE SEATS PEER ANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY OR- YES
THESE ARE LARGE DRONES THAT
AUTHORITY REMAINS RESIDENT WITH
THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE SO
EVERY TIME WE USE A DRONE WHY
USE IT A LARGE STRONG WE HAVE
TO GO TO THE PORTION OF THE
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE. TO GET
PERMISSION OUR GOVERNOR
PERSONALLY INTERVENE IN THE
PAST YEARS AND WAS ABLE TO GET
BLANK FORTY. FOR A YEAR AT A
TIME. THE TO ENABLE US TO VALUE
CLOSEST FOR AWHILE. BUT WE
CAN'T USE THEM WITH GOING
THROUGH. RATHER CUMBERSOME.
FIRST GRAY RESPONSE FOR. IT IS
JUST RESTRICTIVE IN USING TO
SUPPORT LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THIS IS PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE WE
HAVE ABOUT A FOURTEEN LARGE AND
MEDIUM UNMANNED SYSTEMS IN THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD
INVENTORY WE HAVE ONE MANNED
SURVEILLANCE AIRCRAFT THAT WE
USE ON A DAILY BASIS ROUTINELY
TO SUPPORT LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WITH THEIR DRUG
COUNTER NARCOTIC EFFORTS. OF
HIS GOAL OF THE AMOUNT WHEN
THAT THE IN WHICH WILL BE THE
VAN WE WILL HAVE EFFECTIVELY
NOTHING BECAUSE OF THE FENCES
BEEN RELUCTANT TO ALLOW US TO
USE OUR UNMANNED SYSTEMS
EXTRAORDINARY PEOPLE TO ASSIST
LAW ENFORCEMENT DID FLY IN A
DEMONSTRATION IN SUPPORT OF US
YOU BE PERSON DURING THE DAY.
ON WHICH IS A EXERCISE ACTUALLY
CAUGHT A DRUG SMUGGLING BOAT
AND THE AND THE A WAS GOING TO
SEE. IT'S RG THE BILL SO WE
WILL BE REACHING OUT FOR THE
CAR AND PERHAPS LET OF WOULD
HAVE TO GET THE TO OF TO LOOSE
THOSE RESTRICTIONS ON THE USE
OF THEIR AIRCRAFT IT REALLY
DELAY FEAR BECAUSE BY CAN YOU
GO WHEN THERE'S A LOT OF DRONE
AREA THERE WERE PRIVATE EARNS
WE WORK THROUGH ALL THAT WE
HAVE A- UNTIL. IT'S OVER SO.
SYSTEM ALLOWS TO SUPPORT ONE.
TO SUPPORT OTHER FIRST
RESPONDERS WITHOUT VIOLATING
ANYONE CIVIL RIGHTS. THANK YOU.
HI THERE- QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE I'M ESPECIALLY CARD
YEAH YEAH SENATE JOHNSON YEAH
PLEASE ON THE ON THE DRONES-
YOU KNOW FLYING OVER YOUR
AIRCRAFT. THE. I'M JANET MAYBE
IT'S A SIMPLE QUESTION I DON'T
KNOW WHY COULD YOU SHOULD
DOLLARS SHOCK AND- WELL WE
ACTUALLY JOKES ONE OF THE BEST
WAYS KNOCKED ON DRUMS WITH A
FIRE HOSE SO CAN CALL THAT.
YEAH THE PROBLEM IS THAT
THERE'S A LAW ON THE FEDERAL
LAW ON THE BOOKS THAT- DOES NOT
ALLOW YOU INTERFERE WITH.
AIRCRAFT PRIVATE OR COMMERCIAL
AIRCRAFT AND- DRONES EVEN THE
SMALL ONES WORK ARE CLASSIFIED
AS AIRCRAFT SO WOULD BE
VIOLATING THAT FEDERAL LAW IF
WE INTERFERED WITH THE- PLIGHT
OF BETTER. THE VERY PAPER CUP
FLANK INTERIOR BASE WITH. HAVE
NEED IF ACTION ON THAT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IT SAYS THAT IT'S
ACTUALLY THIS. I'M AT. THOSE
ARE CRAFTING WAS CRAP ARMED TO
DO WHAT YOU. THEIR SEPT.
WHETHER IT'S THE RUSSIANS
FLYING BY DOWN THE WHICH ARE
INTERCEPT ROUTE. WELL IT'S
THREATS COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER SOMEONE'S. INTO A
RESTRICTED AIR SPACE BUT
THERE'S A VERY COMPLEX AND
CONVOLUTED PROCESS IN ORDER TO
GET THE AUTHORITY FOR THE
PILOT. SHOULD PULL THE TRIGGER
TO SHOOT. AND AN AIRCRAFT
THAT'S JUST AS BE FLYING OVER
THE BASE BECAUSE NOT RESTRICTED
AIR BASE. PAIRS SPACE. DOESN'T
CALL THAT. CAN I JUST OKAY I
WELL I GUESS THAT PART IS IT SO
PAPRIKA THE GETS LOST IN FOR
OVER A- I THINK ANY. DOWN
EITHER. NO THAT. OKAY ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. THE SERVER IS THAT
AT WHEN WORKING A LOT BUT THE
U. S. FROM HOME AS SECURITY UP
AS YOU KNOW THEY'VE BEEN OUT A
LOT HI. THING GOING ON ABOUT
THIS WAY AT DECK. OF DRUGS IS
DROP BEING OKAY THIS ALL WENT
BAD. YOU KNOW FIFTY AN HOUR I
MEAN. SO YOU KNOW. I AM A- IN
END ALL DHS TEST THEY'VE DONE.
REGULAR SHOOTING WITH WITH WITH
YOU KNOW RIFLE AND SHOTGUNS AND
MACHINE GUNS. AND FOR HOSE THE
TO THE WHOLE REALLY THE WAY YOU
INTERDICTED HIS THROUGH JAN.
TECH AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT
JERRY WALLACE TALK ABOUT AND
THAT'S WHAT WE IT CURRENTLY AT
THE FOR LEVEL WE NEED GET THAT
MOVED DOWN THE STATE AND LOCAL
FOR THAT PURPOSE AS FASTEST WAY
AND THERE'S CAPABILITIES AND
ACTUALLY NOT TO YEAH BUT WHAT.
OUR GOES INTO A AND THEIR SPACE.
AND JUST BRING IT RIGHT DOWN TO
THE GROUND AND- AND BASICALLY
RENDER IT. UNUSABLE SO WHERE
WE'VE BEEN YOU KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A TON OF TESTING IN THIS
AREA IT'S JUST A MATTER OF
GETTING IT TRANSFERRED AND
THAT'S REALLY WHERE. I MADE
SOME SERVICES. HELPFUL IN YOU
AND MAYBE WE SHOULD HAVE
DEPARTMENT CORRECTIONS HERE TO
ANSWER THIS QUESTION IT. DO YOU
KNOW WHAT DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS IS DOING BECAUSE I.
KNOW YOU MENTIONED IT- IT IS
BECOMING A PROBLEM IN THE STATE
PRISON I WOULD ASSUME FOR
PRISONS IS WELL. YOU KNOW. IS
DEPARTMENT ACTIONS DO ANYTHING
SENATOR THERE ARE THERE THEY
WERE VERY SO WITH AS THEY'RE
THEY'RE THEY'RE IN THE SAME
LIMITATION THAT THE REST. OF ON
INTERDICTION. FUTURE PROBLEMS
WITH BRING CONTRA OVER THE
FENCE LINE AND- YOU KNOW. BASIC.
OKAY BILL OF THE TWO BECAUSE OF
THE POP THE LAW THEN JUST
MENTION. THAT TO ENTERED SO IF
THE WATCH FOR IT. AND THEN
THERE THEIR THEIR BASE JUST
RESPOND AT THIS CONTRABAND
DROPPED OVER THEY THEY SEND
OUT- OFFICER OUT THE
INTERDICTED. AND THE LAW THE
MISSION IS A FEDERAL LAW YES
THAT'S CORRECT YEAH YEAH ALOT
ACOSTA WITH FHA IS REALLY.
REALLY THE ENTITY THAT IS THE
PRIMARY FEDERAL AGENCY HERE.
AND ARE THEY JUST DRAGGING
THEIR FEET ON THIS OR THEY JUST
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT THERE'S
TOO MANY GOOD IDEAS TOO MANY
BAD IDEAS. I THINK IT'S A
LITTLE BIT OF ALL THE ABOVE-
YOU KNOW- THROUGH THE THIS IS
SUCH A EVOLVING TECHNOLOGY THAT
TRYING TO FIGURE IT OUT BUT-
YOU KNOW THERE'S BEEN SOME.
SOME REPORTS THAT THAT I'VE
READ AND THEN PUT OUT ABOUT
EVENTUALLY BEING YOU KNOW HERE
FOUR DOORS THAT ARE DROWNED
DRIVEN BECAUSE YOU HAVE.
COMPANIES LIKE. AMAZON EXCEPT
FOR THAT WANT TO DELIVER. PHONE
SIX CETERA AND SO THEY'RE
THEY'RE GONNA THEY- THE- IS ON
FOR DOING THAT. THERE'S GOT TO
BE A LAW ENFORCEMENT PIECE TO
THAT TO BE ABLE TO INTERDICT
PROPRIA LEE- I THINK WE'RE
CLOSE BUT- IT'S STILL NOT THERE
YET. IS IT IN YOUR OPINION IS
THERE ANYTHING THAT THIS
COMMITTEE CAN. HELP INCREASE
CONGRESS. ARE AVE AIR WE YEAH I
DON'T GO THERE WOULD ABSOLUTELY
AT SO WE CAN WE CAN PROVIDE. HE
BACK BACK THIS COMMIT AND THE
B. HELP AND I THINK OF A LETTER
OR IN. ABSOLUTELY THIS WHAT. I
MEAN WE HAVE TO DO TO. THEN IT.
WILL AND WE'VE HEARD THIS IS
THE FOURTH OR FIFTH YEAR IN A
ROW NOW THAT WE'VE FOR YOU ALL.
YOU KNOW SHARE THE CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS ISSUE IT'S NOT. IT
SEEMS LIKE TO ME IT'S A STROKE
OF A PEN EASY THING TO. HIS UP.
AS COMMITTEE WE ARE TAKE IT
UPON OURSELVES IS LEAD HEARING
TO WORK WITH YOU SAID BREAK
DOWN THE ROAD BLOCK WHEREVER IT
IS APPRECIATE THAT I THINK
WE'LL WILL PROPOSE SUGGEST YOU
KNOW LANGUAGE FOR YOU GUYS TO
DO THAT THANK YOU WE CAN HAVE
STAFF OR WITH YOUR OFFICE
RELATED MAKE IT BETTER. WE YEAH
THE SCENE SHARES DOWN AT A
STORE THERE OKAY. ALL RIGHT
MEMBER OF CONGRESS TO THE FACT
GOT OUR A VISIONARY DAYS SERMON
IN THE OF STARTING ELEVEN THAT
I KNOW WE HAVE TO THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS SO IF THERE ARE STILL
PEOPLE WANT TO COMMENT PLEASE
KEEP IT. DID YOU A BRIEF- BUT
IF I'M NOT SEE ANYBODY I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
PARTICIPATION IS ANYTHING IDEAS
A COUPLE STOPS OR ANY TAKING
COMING OUT OF THIS MEETING IN
AND OBVIOUSLY A TOUGH HARD WORK
IT ALSO GOES BEHIND ALL
PRESENTATIONS. AS ACTED SO AYE
AYE PRE. I BY EVERYONE'S
PARTICIPATION IN HARD WORK ON
THIS TOPIC IN LET'S ALL MEET
OUTSIDE OF THE WEST UPS IS
GOING TO BE A CEREMONY OPENING
AVIATION AEROSPACE DAYS FOR
THIS. WEEK THIS THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED. MILITARY PRECISION
OKAY. YEAH. YEAH ALSO. THE
NATION'S YEAH YEAH YEAH LAST
MINUTE CHANGES. SUBPROBLEM
SAYING YES AND THEN I.